Microphone Check Jocko.
How are you sir?
I'm doing pretty good.
How are you feeling?
Splendid,
especially given this,
this cocktail of adrenaline that you've been feeding me
flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
[inaudible]
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them,
and this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they'd put you in and if you just want to take their
advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it and here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't great investing
is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest a $30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use wealth front yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of SCC regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user and have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account,
but just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim.
It's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Now I do have to read a mandatory disclaimer.
Wealthfront Inc is an SEC registered investment advisor.
Investing in securities involves risks and there is the possibility of losing
money.
Past performance is no guarantee of future results.
Please visit wealthfront.com to read their full disclosure,
so check it out.
Guys.
This is one of the hottest,
most innovative companies coming out of Silicon Valley and they're killing it.
They've become massively popular.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you,
and you can use that information however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world and here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they are chess prodigies like Josh Waitzkin actors and governor tells
like Arnold Schwarzenegger or anything in between professional athletes,
you name it,
I want to talk to them because you find that at the very highest level at the
top of the top in each field and across those fields,
their commonalities and I want to tease out the morning routines,
the habits,
the favorite books and so on that you can apply immediately to your life to
level up and this episode is no exception.
This episode was a very intense episode.
My guest is someone who very rarely does any interviews,
Jocko Willink,
He is a legend in the seal community.
He's also 240 pounds or so,
230 to 240 pounds of lean muscle.
He would routinely tap out 20 or so navy seals as a workouts and CC Brazilian
Jujitsu,
a practitioner at a world class level and also trains professional MMA fighters
in his spare time.
But dialing back to the beginning.
Jocko grew up in a small new England town,
enlisted in the navy after high school and spent 20 years in the seal teams.
During his second tour in Iraq,
he led seal task unit bruiser in the battle of Ramadi,
which was some of the toughest,
most sustained combat in the seal teams since Vietnam.
Under his leadership task unit,
bruiser help bring stability to Ramadi and became the most highly decorated
special operations unit of the entire war in Iraq.
Jocko is subsequently awarded the bronze star and Silver Star.
After that.
Returning from that deployment,
Jocko served as the officer in charge of training for all west coast seal teams,
which means he designed and implemented some of the most challenging and
realistic combat training in the world.
He also spearheaded the development of CEO Leadership Training and therefore
personally instructed and mentor the next generation of steel leaders.
In 2010 chocolate retired from the navy to cofound echelon front,
that's e.
Never knew how to pronounce that Echelon Front,
a leadership and management consulting company which teaches leadership
principles learned and proven in combat to help others lead.
And when,
and this is very interesting because you can view combat in many ways as sort of
an exaggeration of many states in situations that one experiences in other areas
of life including business Jocko is last but not least,
the author of a brand new book,
extreme ownership.
That's the title.
And we get into what that means.
Uh,
I am really enjoying this book,
extreme ownership subtitle,
how US Navy Seals lead and win.
I highly encourage you check this book out.
Even if you just read the,
the intro and chapters one,
six and 12,
even if you just do that,
the book is worth many times the price.
So check it out.
I highly encourage it.
And you can find jocko@echelonfront.com e c h e l o,
n and also on Twitter.
I am helping train him to use Twitter.
A lot of these guys,
the uh,
Navy seals and other divisions of the military do not like to be public facing.
But Jocko is going to be on Twitter.
So at Jocko Willink,
j,
O,
c k,
O,W ,
I,
l,
N K and you can probably also check out a photo of this guy which you have to
see and as always you can find all show notes,
links to everything we talk about@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast all
spelled out.
Just go to four hour workweek.com and click on podcast and you can also find all
previous episodes.
So without further ado,
please enjoy this very intense,
very insightful conversation with Jocko Willink.
We do get into the weeds and I implore you,
I encourage you to bear with us if we get into a bunch of military specifics
because there are gems throughout this conversation and even if you only take
one or two a way,
it is well worth the time invested.
So thank you for listening and please enjoy.
Okay,
we are alive,
Casa Ferris.
Jocko,
welcome to the show.
Glad to be here.
Thrilled to have you here.
And looking at your bio and talking to people who know you,
the number of topics we
could discuss our are many and extremely interesting,
but I'll start with this tea.
What is this?
I suppose it's a pinkish colored liquid that you've been consuming and that uh,
you've shared with me.
It's a pomegranate white tea,
which I believe hit your soul pretty well.
Well,
I was surprised because I expected it to have low caffeine content.
I was like,
sure,
I'll try the tea.
It sounds like,
you know,
with the pomegranate and I'm like maybe it would help with my cramps or
something and I'm pretty well lit up for someone who drinks,
you know,
Pooh air tea,
Oolong tea,
I guess sort of a,
a veteran of indirect caffeine consumption with,
with leaves.
I,
I've been impressed.
How long have you been drinking this?
I forget when I stumbled upon it,
but
we used to do some desert training back when I was in the seal teams actually
when I was running the training on the west coast.
And,
uh,
I would have to sit through the platoons briefs as they were getting ready to go
out in the field and do a field training exercise.
And the briefs were about an hour long and we'd be on three or four hours of
sleep a night for a few days.
And so at some point I discovered this stuff and I would start drinking it when
the brief kicked off.
And by the time the brief ended,
I would have taken copious notes and be ready to get after the platoon
commanders that were,
uh,
trying to give good briefs and I'd,
I'd,
I'd get after it.
You'd be fired up for feedback?
Affirmative.
Did.
And,
uh,
you mentioned that you don't normally consume caffeine.
Is that true?
I do not normally can consume caffeine.
Now,
when do you,
what are some examples of when you reserve a,
or or when you do consume caffeine?
What's the use of caffeine?
Some kind of long drive,
you know,
so,
um,
you know,
even my first deployment to Iraq,
we did longer patrols in the vehicles and I would have,
you know,
uh,
right in front of my seat.
So sort of hanging in front of my seat,
I'd have a,
a flash bang grenade,
and then another Flashband grenade,
and then a frag grenade,
which is the grenade that you know,
kills people.
And then another frag grenade.
And then the next three patches were red bull,
red bull,
red bull.
So you know,
if you're going on a long patrol,
and I know it might seem strange that you would get tired,
but you would,
you know,
and,
and so you crack open a red bull and get after it.
And then that's the kind of occasions I would save the caffeine intake for what
now we haven't spent too much time together.
We've been hanging out.
And you had an ice tea?
I had a couple of coffees and I feel like I've,
I've just belligerently unnecessarily punched my adrenal glands for so many
years that the coffee pretty much does nothing to me.
But,
uh,
you're an intense guy,
which has meant as a compliment.
What do you like on three red bulls
more Jocko.
And how did you get the nickname Jocko?
Uh,
actually my parents gave me that nickname.
Oh,
they did?
Huh,
that's,
that's uh,
my real name is John,
but ever since I was born I've been called Jocko.
So
that's what everyone knows me as.
And uh,
when you,
and of course we're going to talk a lot about your time deployed and a training
other,
um,
other people,
but let's take a look at your physique.
So,
so we were introduced through a p to Tiaa has also been on this podcast.
Very funny,
very smart guy.
And he said,
you have to ask Jocko about his weight gain.
Now this is not bad weekend cause right now you're about how much would you say
to 30,
to 35 to 30.
If you're agreeing you'd be at the health care big guy,
uh,
and uh,
very fit.
But when you entered the seals,
how much did you weigh?
One 74.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well that's when I,
when I started seal training and weighed 174 pounds.
And how did that transformation take place?
I mean,
was it,
was it just an a growth spurt or were you facilitating that with a resistance
training?
How did that come about?
So I entered seal training and 174 pounds.
And you know,
everyone's seen what seal training is like.
It's a lot of pushups,
a lot of pull ups,
a lot of dips,
running,
swimming,
obstacle course.
Uh,
I just ate what they fed us,
which is what they feed you a lot.
And in the course of seal training I put on,
I think I graduated 185 pounds.
And then once I was done with that and started getting in seal platoons,
you know,
and we all lifted heavy and wanted to be big and strong.
And so I lifted heavy and ate a lot.
And I think I put on,
I was up to 200 my first platoon.
And then after that I got up to about two 25 and now depending on what's
happening in the,
in the fight game and who I'm training with and what they're preparing for,
I'll go up to,
you know,
to 42 45 if I need to and then come back down once,
those events are over.
So in other words,
I'll be,
if I'm training a guy that's a heavyweight or,
or fighting a heavyweight,
then I'll put on some weight so I can simulate that better.
What type of training would you suggest for people with type of regimen?
What,
uh,
what might a workout or a week look like for someone who wants to,
let's just say a male,
25 years old who wants to add a lean mass?
We dead lift and squat,
deadlift in squat.
I mean,
I think that's the universal answer,
right?
Yeah.
Does anyone say anything different when you're asked that question?
I don't ask.
I don't ask many people.
But you have,
you have such an incredible range of weight over that period of time that I had
to ask.
I mean,
I think that is the right answer.
Um,
I think the eating is a lot harder than the training in some respects leads from
me.
I mean,
I got up to,
I'm walking around about one 75 right now,
but I did to beat a friend and a bet,
which didn't even involve money.
So,
I'm not sure why I subjugated myself to this or subject myself to this,
but,
uh,
I got up to like two 15 mm.
Uh,
the eating was a harder component.
I remember being on a deployment on a ship and so the food on the ship is not
good.
You know,
you're on a six month deployment on a ship and I was a seal.
And when you're on a ship,
as
a CEO,
you're not,
you don't have,
you don't have a job other than just a workout.
This is especially,
you know,
in the 90s.
So it was a totally different world,
the dry years because there's no war going on.
And I remember your,
we're all just trying to get huge.
And I remember getting a plates full of chicken mcnuggets or whatever brand they
serve in the navy.
And I would just be sitting there at a table,
you know,
for 40 minutes after chow was done being served.
And I'm just looking at these chicken nuggets and hating them and putting them
into my mouth and forcing them down in order to gain weight.
So yeah,
stupid,
but requires dedication.
And there there's something to be said for,
you know,
if to use one of your terms.
I'm a worldclass chicken nugget eater when I need to be.
Uh,
let's talk about,
um,
the MMA and then we're going to come back to military.
When did you first get exposed to Jujitsu or martial arts?
So I'm on my first deployment in 1992 or 1993 and I'm in Guam and there's an old
seal master chief named Steve Bailey.
And he was kind of known as a bad ass.
In fact,
he was known as a bad ass.
And the reason he was known as a bad ass,
it's because he was a bad ass.
And so this is pre UFC,
no one knows anything and he has been training for a year or something with the
Gracies up in Torrance.
And he took a bunch of us new guys and said,
hey,
does anyone want to learn how to fight?
And of course,
absolutely want to learn how to fight myself and a couple of the guys and uh,
you know,
he was like a high level white belt,
maybe even a medium level white belt,
but it's 1993,
you know,
and no one know all new.
So he,
you know,
he taught us,
the rear naked choke,
the arm lock,
how to escape the amount and possibly in Americana.
Yeah.
We're staying on the chest into,
right.
And so with those moves,
you know,
and there's a lot of,
being in the seal teams,
you're constantly,
I mean,
it's a,
it's an environment where there's lots of escalations,
you know,
in a platoon.
And so you're constantly scrapping and wrestling and fighting and you know,
uh,
that's part of it.
And so,
but with these basic maneuvers that I learned,
I could do well,
you know,
and it was,
it was bad ass.
So that's when I started at,
and then I w I didn't really see it.
Didn't we have the vision?
You know,
I thought that it was,
you couldn't see where it would go.
I thought it was a finite thing.
I know these seven moves,
everyone that's stepped up to me now I've been able to handle.
I am good.
I'm,
I,
you know,
I'm good.
And it wasn't until one of my other buddies who is a CEO who was in that initial
pack with me,
um,
a guy by the name of Jeff Higgs and he had kind of,
he had gotten out of the seal teams and he'd just dedicated himself to train in
Jujitsu.
And one day he came to my house and you know,
we were even when we were both idiots,
right.
And he came to my house one day and he says,
Hey,
you want to train?
And I said,
well,
yeah,
absolutely.
So we went over in the grass across the street from my house and you know,
he,
he had just gotten his purple belt.
So you can imagine a purple belt in 1995.
Yeah,
I mean he was just completely beyond anything.
I knew.
He tapped me out thousand times and I said,
hey,
were,
were you training to me the place?
And that was,
it went down the next day and signed up for unlimited classes and I took three
classes a day until the present time.
Three lessons a day.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would just go during lunch,
I'd go to the,
the beginner class.
I'd go to the advanced class.
I would just get after it.
And,
uh,
who was he training with?
Do you recall who he was from?
Fabio Santos,
lobbyists and tips.
And let's flash forward to the current day.
Uh,
who are the primary teachers you've trained with and what's,
what's these current status of your Jujitsu and training?
Well,
my,
uh,
long story short,
myself and being lister,
uh,
we ended up not being with Fabio anymore and we ended up kind of going out on
her own.
Dean went out or Arizona and I was,
I was,
you know,
an active duty seal,
so I wasn't a fulltime Jujitsu Guy,
but,
uh,
but I was a fulltime main training partner for Dean and so we left and we ended
up going to a couple different schools and eventually opened a,
a big gym down in San Diego.
And we have dean lister and Jeff Glover,
uh,
our,
our primary instructors.
What's the name of the school?
Victory.
MMA Victoria.
And,
and,
uh,
how did,
what was your experience opening a business as an active seal?
How did your military experience help or hinder that?
You know,
I'd say it was typical stuff.
Hey,
okay,
let's figure out what the plan is going to be.
How are we going to put it together?
I,
you know,
it was opening a gym.
We weren't,
you know,
planning and we weren't,
we were building a railroad.
It wasn't,
it was a lot less than even planning a,
a regular seal mission.
Um,
in a lot of ways,
which again,
planting sealed admissions is no,
is no,
you know,
high intellectual tasks either.
I mean,
you've got bad guys are going to go kill him.
That's,
that's not super advanced.
And of course there's technology and timelines and all that,
but it's not,
it's not rocket science.
And so I,
you know,
we did a good job and opened up a big space and teach you a bunch of Jujitsu,
so,
okay.
Got It.
So it's as far as,
instead of tactical implementation,
not the most complex thing that you've done,
what would you,
what would you put on the,
uh,
the higher level and of,
of complexity in terms of things that you've spearheaded or,
uh,
had to tackle up to this point here?
There's two types of complexity that you,
that you know,
we could talk about here.
There's the actual complexity of the mission,
which again,
in generally is not going to be super complex.
But what is complex is yet you're dealing with human beings who have,
you know,
all these variables,
emotions and problems and issues and egos.
And that's the complexity in anything.
And so that's from a leadership perspective,
that's what I've found to be always the more challenging thing.
You know,
that's always the more challenging thing is dealing with people and getting
people to,
you know,
conduct operations or carry out missions in a way that is most efficient,
most effective,
especially when you know,
they could get killed doing it.
And you know,
you're asking guys to do things that are very,
very dangerous where they know they could die.
And so that's what's complex.
That's what's complex.
And,
and it transfers over to the business world where you've got to get,
you know,
a group of people.
It's the same thing.
You've got to get a group of people to carry out a mission and that,
you know,
they in the most efficient and effective manner.
So they both have that in common.
And I think that is usually the more complex pieces of the leadership of human
beings.
Sure.
Well,
I mean it's,
uh,
makes me think of,
I guess custom auto who worked with Tyson for so long and really took him to his
first world championship belt.
He said,
you know,
everyone has a plan until they get hit in the face.
And I think that when you have something's very simple on paper,
but there are a lot of unknown or uncontrollable variables.
The plan is just a starting point.
But then you have to adjust in the field and obviously when the stakes are as
high as they are,
uh,
when you were deployed,
I,
I can see how that would be infinitely complex potentially in it,
depending on,
on how sideways things go.
Well,
how did you become a seal?
What's,
what's the story of you becoming a seal?
Well,
I grew up in New England and I actually grew up in a little town in the sticks
of New England and I was kind of a rebellious kid.
In fact,
I was a pretty significantly rebellious kid.
And,
and I know it seems counterintuitive,
but when you grow up in New England,
um,
one of the most rebellious things that a human being can do is join the military
and almost the,
the ultra rebellious thing you could do.
Cause,
you know,
it's very,
uh,
you know,
I grew up with a bunch of hippies,
kids were hippies,
they were dead heads,
they were smoking pot.
And I was not into that.
And I was so,
so they thought they were rebellious because they were smoking pot and doing
acid and whatnot.
And,
uh,
I don't know,
you tell me who was more rebellious because I ended up becoming a commando for
my whole life.
I think the,
the,
the sort of pot and hacky sack seen,
I've spent a lot of time in Vermont and New Hampshire at that exact seems kind
of par for the course.
It's like a sort of conformist rebellion.
Uh,
but the uh,
in,
what was the path that you took then?
So it was a,
at what point did you enlist?
So I actually,
uh,
1989 and Panama happens,
the invasion of Panama happened and for seals were killed there.
And when I saw that in the paper,
I was,
I guess the word would be ashamed that I was not there.
I,
you know,
the Vietnam War was over,
so we weren't seeing headlines all the time.
And all of a sudden there's guys that were dying for the,
for,
for our country.
And I was not there.
And right after that I went down to the recruiting station and said I wanted to
be a seal.
And what happens after that?
So then,
you know,
I went to bootcamp,
which is Navy boot camp,
got done with bootcamp,
and his boot camp is separate from bud.
It is,
it is separate.
And then you go to a school where you learn a navy trade and then you start
buds.
So started buds in,
I think it was April of 1991 so this was right after the Gulf War.
So from my perspective leading up to the Gulf War there,
you know,
there were some reports.
I remember hearing him on the news.
They're saying there's going to be 40,000 casualties in the first 24 hours.
I don't know if you remember that,
but I remember that.
Don't remember that.
I remember that because I was in the military and I was going to seal training.
I was in China when I saw the announcement on television.
So,
so here I am thinking,
okay,
this is going to be,
I'm going to get some,
you know,
I'm going to,
I'm going to go to war,
you know,
all these guys are gonna get hurt and injured,
killed,
and I'm going to go to war.
And the war kicks off in 72 hours later.
It's over.
And I hadn't even started seal training yet,
so I was pretty bummed out.
I know that sounds crazy,
but you know,
I was pretty bummed out because that's what I wanted to do with my life was
being combat and be some kind of warrior and now the chance had just dissipated
in 72 hours.
Uh,
but you know,
it was the reality of what was happening.
So went to seal training,
went through and went over to seal team one and in let's say boot camp just for
people listening and for myself quite quite frankly,
who are not familiar with what happens in these different phases does,
does uh,
is the objective,
what is the objective of bootcamp in,
in the,
in,
uh,
this is the case of the boot camp that you attended and then buds for instance,
because I think a lot of people are familiar with the term like hell,
we can think they think of buds as a disqualifying phase,
right?
The objective is to weed out the people who,
who aren't suitable for combat or leadership or fill in the blank.
But what,
what,
what are,
what are the objectives of bootcamp?
So bootcamp is to get a severe turn,
a civilian into a military human and you know,
they teach you all this basic stuff.
I'd say the key thing that they teach you in navy boot camp is attention to
detail.
So you've got to do all these tasks because if you're in the navy,
you're working on an aircraft and if you make a mistake working on the aircraft,
people die.
So it's very attention to detail oriented and they just teach you the basic
structure of the military and imprint that on your brain.
Right.
And then,
and then seal training is,
is what it is.
What you said it is,
it's weeding people out.
And what is the of the say incoming an apologist,
I'm going to mask or the terminology here,
but of the incoming class,
how many people go into buds and how many people make it out?
The other end,
it's,
it's about an 80% attrition rate.
80% attrition.
So 20% make it through.
Yup.
And uh,
do you have to ring a bell?
Is that natural thing?
How does that work?
Can you describe the
yeah,
they have a bell and if you want to quit you can quit at any time.
And if you want to quit,
you walk over to this bell that they carry on all the runs and they have it in
the back of a truck.
And if you want to quit,
you go over and ring the bell and then you're done.
And then you're done.
What did you find most challenging personally in the buds training,
if anything?
You know,
the thing with buds is,
um,
you know,
I was not good at anything.
I wasn't great at anything.
I couldn't run fast,
I couldn't swim fast,
but I was like okay at everything,
which is actually better because you didn't have a single failure point.
I didn't have these areas of weakness are huge weakness.
Now again,
I was not,
believe me,
I'm not saying that I was great at anything because I really wasn't.
I finish to the middle of the pack on Iran in the middle of the pack of the
swim.
Uh,
there were some guys,
you know what I,
a couple of guys that I remember that were at the other end of the spectrum,
we had a guy that played,
you know,
college,
Ncaa Water Polo,
and he was a phenomenal athlete and he quit because he couldn't get through the
obstacle course.
I had another guy in my class that was a,
uh,
was,
was an Olympic gymnast alternate.
And he quit because the water and you know,
doing the stuff in the water got to them.
So for me,
luckily I grew up in the water and I grew up in New England,
so I was used to cold that didn't do anything to me.
And you know,
all you had to do is get the passing and put out as hard as you can,
you know,
like for the runs,
I had to run as hard as I could to pass the runs.
It was a sprint,
uh,
because you couldn't modulate,
he didn't know how long the runs really word.
They'd say they were four miles,
but you had no idea what they were actually going to be.
So you just had to run as hard as you possibly could.
If that's what I had to do.
Right.
That's got to be a quite a mind trip.
I mean,
to start a run when it's not a primary strength and no,
you have to go all out without having any idea of the length of,
well you'd know it was going to be around role models.
I don't want to make it sound like it.
We had no idea,
but it was um,
you know,
we,
it'd be,
it'd be four and a half miles,
you know,
four and three quarter miles or whatever.
Did the people who made it through the 20% who made it through buds,
um,
did the people who showed the most promise in buds ended up performing best in
the field?
Not necessarily because Bud's isn't,
is a much more athletic
event.
Right?
It's about athleticism.
A lot of it,
a lot of it is also,
you know,
don't quit.
And,
you know,
I hear some people say everybody thinks about quitting during seal training.
And I absolutely did not think about quitting at any time.
You know,
there was nothing if they could have killed me and it would have been fine,
but I definitely wasn't gonna quit.
And,
but when you get to the seal team,
yeah,
there were some guys that,
that you that were stud athletically but they were not great seals when they got
the teams.
And there's also guys that are studs athletically that were studs in the seal
teams.
So it's hard to put up a scientific answer around that one.
Yeah,
we'll come back to the training.
Cause I just,
I I loved talking about in any types of commonalities or patterns that you've
spotted in a couple of different areas.
But I'm
going to ask you about the bottle,
the,
the battle of Ramadi.
But I want to first ask,
where did you get this mental toughness?
So this,
this not thinking of quitting,
even if it killed you,
was that developed through athletics as a kid through something else?
Is your entire family like that?
I mean,
where did that,
where did that come from?
Where'd that drive?
And then sticktuitiveness come from?
I'm not 100% sure.
Um,
some of it,
you know,
I remember,
my dad was definitely,
you're not allowed to quit at anything ever.
So that leaves a mark.
Roger.
Also,
I think that,
you know,
I grew up and I,
I started listening to hardcore music and I had a hardcore attitude.
And so I think that growing up under that influence,
you know,
that and watching war movies and you know,
a product of,
of that,
you know,
of that influence of those mantras that you'd hear in some hardcore song that's
about,
you know,
getting after it.
And I think that that left a mark as well.
Uh,
could you describe the battle of Ramadi at and,
uh,
explain what that is for people who may not even recognize the name or muddy.
So the battle of Ramadi.
So Ramadi is a city in western Iraq,
in a state or province called all on bar problems,
which is the largest province in Iraq.
And Ramadi is the capital city and the battle of Ramadi that that I fought in
was in 2006 and at that time,
most of the,
or many of the insurgents had been pushed out of Baghdad.
Many of them had been pushed out of fellowship because the Marine Corps did a
very,
a substantial effort through Fallujah and cleared it out.
And a lot of those enemy had gone to Ramadi.
So in the summer of 2006 the epicenter of the insurgency was in Ramadi.
And so that's where my seal task unit deployed to and that's where we fought.
How long were you there?
We were there for six months.
For six months.
How do you,
how would you describe that experience to people?
And I know that's a very broad question,
but for,
for,
for lack of a better way to approach it,
because I mean we can,
we can really peel back the layers,
but when people ask you what was that like?
How do you answer that?
Well,
for one thing,
it was my second deployment to Iraq.
So my first deployment to Iraq was
completely different in that the insurgency hadn't been really a truly
established and we as a country,
this is 2003,
2004 and so we were doing very well,
you know,
at least everyone thought we were and we were winning.
And you know,
I always talk about that deployment.
Like we were rock stars because we,
you know,
one o'clock in the morning we'd drive out of the gate and go capture bad guy and
bring them back at three o'clock in the morning.
And it was like we were rock stars.
You know,
we had,
um,
we had such a tactical advantage over the enemy and it was just pretty,
pretty easy.
We always worked with seals only.
It was just,
it was just easy.
Um,
tough.
Of course I'm not,
I shouldn't say easy,
but it was less challenging.
And,
and on that deployment it was like we won everything and we felt great.
We felt great about what we did.
We felt like we accomplished our mission.
And you know,
if those were the challenges of combat as an individual,
I felt like I did a good job.
Right.
And you're well equipped.
I did a good job and,
and my truth did.
My platoon did a good job.
We did a good job and it was,
it seemed like we passed a test,
you know like cause you know at that time we hadn't had sustained combat
operations for a long time in the seal teams.
So we felt pretty bad.
Awesome.
So now you fast forward to Ramadi in 2006 it is completely different.
There are insurgents that actually control a majority of the city.
They are,
have complete freedom to maneuver.
They are terrorizing and I don't use that term lightly.
They are terrorizing.
They're skinning people alive.
They're beheading people,
they're doing what you see on TV right now with Isis.
They're doing that.
The civilian population is horrified and there are 30 to 50 enemy attacks a day.
In the city of Ramadi.
There are route Michigan,
which is a road that ran from east to west through Ramadi,
which was loosely controlled by Americans,
would have seven to 10 IED attacks,
IED attacks a day.
So this is the statistically the most IED road in all of Iraq and it's three
miles long
improvised explosive device,
improvised explosive device.
So these are a roadside bombs that completely caused the majority of casualties
in the war in Iraq.
And so we get there,
you know,
the,
the buildings are rumbled out,
the buildings have bullet holes in them.
There's wrecked vehicles on the streets,
there's giant craters in the streets from iads.
And on top of all that,
on an almost daily basis,
you're going to some kind of a memorial ceremony for an American soldier,
an American marine that's been killed in combat.
And we rolled into that.
And right away I knew this is completely different situation and we are going to
fight a completely different type of battle here.
We're the A in this case,
I mean looking at your opponents,
were they better trained or did they just have a sort of territorial and
movement advantage,
um,
that that made it more difficult for you guys?
They had both.
They both had both.
So there was a former military base,
former Iraqi military base or you as,
so you had a lot of former regime people,
their soldiers,
former soldiers that were there.
They definitely controlled the terrain without question.
They acted they were allowed to fight in a completely different way than us.
And by that I mean they have no rules,
right?
So you're fighting it.
Someone that has no rules and you know,
they don't care about collateral damage.
We are,
we are very careful about collateral damage.
They don't care is to define that.
You mean taking out civilians,
people who were civilian casualties.
It means nothing to them.
Destroying a building means nothing to them.
Um,
killing each other.
So accidentally shooting or suicide bombers,
I mean there,
there were suicide bombers on the regular in Ramadi and so they have no rules.
And so that gave them an advantage as well.
Now tactically they did what we did.
So for example,
you know,
if we get into a bad firefight,
we'll call for reinforcements.
Reinforcements will come to help us.
We would watch them do the exact same thing.
If we had someone get wounded,
we would call for a casualty evacuation.
They'd come and pick them up and take them back to the field medical facility.
We would watch them do the exact same thing.
So they had communications,
they had plans,
they would,
they would hit with complex attacks that would be coordinated throughout the
city.
So at one time they would attack three or four different coalition outposts in
the city or on the outskirts of the city,
all coordinated,
you know,
not only amongst themselves.
So the separate attacks would be coordinated,
but the individual attacks would be coordinated where they were vicious,
usually ending,
you know,
starting with machine gun fire and then rocket propelled grenades.
And then their goal always was to get a suicide vehicle,
a suicide vehicle bomb,
and drive it right into the compound and detonate and kill as many people as
possible.
And they did this on the regular
in that type of will.
What was the,
uh,
what was your unit?
What was your unit notice?
Seal team three task unit bruiser and how many people were in that unit?
So when that unit,
you got about 35 seals and then we have another 70 support people.
So these are people that,
you know,
help us fix our vehicles,
get our intelligence,
man,
our radios and all that.
So that,
so you've got about a pretty big,
pretty big contingent of support people.
They're not seals,
they're seals support.
Got It.
So about roughly like a hundred 105 people in total,
do those 35 seals,
uh,
do they all directly report to you?
So in of those 35 seals,
there's two seal platoons with,
you know,
16 guys each.
And then we have a small headquarters element.
Myself and a couple of their guys got it.
And that was the most decorated special operations unit in the Iraq war.
It was what,
what separates a good commander from a great commander in an environment like
that
out of the gate?
You know,
my immediate answer is humility because you're in a situation like that,
there's no way that,
you know,
everything.
It just,
it's not possible.
And so you have to be humble enough to,
you know,
reach out,
ask people for advice.
There had been a,
there've been conventional units,
so big army units,
you know,
I'm on the ground for years and when we got there,
there'd be a new unit on the ground,
the two to eight uh,
iron soldiers from Pennsylvania.
I'm just giving them some props right now cause they were awesome and they,
they'd been on the ground for 14 months fighting.
So we went to those guys and we said,
okay,
well how can we help?
What can we do?
What advice do you have for us?
Uh,
we wanted to learn what they knew and I think that that was a big piece of it.
And also,
you know,
I had an open mind when it came to the strategic mission that we were trying to
accomplish because for many years,
what seals and special operations and the conventional units were doing was
going out into neighborhoods,
grabbing bad guys.
And coming back to the basis.
And
after three years of that,
the enemy attacks had gone up 300%.
So clearly something was not working.
And the the brigade that came in and took over again,
I'm going to give some,
a huge complements to the one one eight d under Colonel Sean McFarland.
They came in with an amazing strategy,
which was seized,
clear hold and build,
which meant you got these bad neighborhoods that are owned by the enemy.
And okay,
we're going to go in there and we're going to stay there.
And that was a very different strategy than anyone had used.
And so that's the CS.
That's the one that is the C's,
clear hold and build.
So you go into these enemy territories and you actually take over a building or
two buildings or three buildings and you make them your house,
make them your forte.
And so that,
so that's what we did.
And again,
so from my perspective,
uh,
you know,
for Carl McFarland and the rest of the battalion commanders and all of those
commanders to this open mind to try out a new,
a completely new strategy,
which was very,
very dangerous area,
dangerous.
I mean,
I'm not an expert.
That sounds very risky.
It was extremely risky and you know,
there was a huge price was paid.
Um,
the casualties were very significant and very horrifying.
Now,
despite that overall,
was that an effective strategy?
It absolutely,
that was just the price that it exists.
It absolutely was.
So by the time I left the strategy hadn't,
we hadn't seen the results yet.
I left October 21st,
2006 by any and there were still about 30 to 50 enemy attacks a day.
About five months after we left the enemy attacks,
we're down to one a day,
two a day from what was from 30 to 50.
Wow.
And then,
and then six months later it was down to one a week and then one a month.
And then soon,
you know,
by 2007,
Ramadi was the safest place in Iraq.
I mean if excluding maybe the curd controlled area up in the north.
And do you attribute that to anything else outside of this?
Uh,
this stratagem the,
the,
the CS.
I'm apologizing that I'm forgetting the,
the others,
but occupying these buildings or areas and making them your home for a period of
time.
Where there other tactical decisions or strategies that contributed to that
decrease?
So the other,
well obviously the other huge piece of this is the men and women that were
fighting and God blessed them all because it was
a hell of a fight.
And like I said,
there was significant casualties and the other focus now was to take back the
neighborhoods and in that secure the populace.
So in other wars,
you know,
you say,
okay,
here's our strategic objective is to take this hail or take this airfield or,
or what or what have you.
And this one,
the goal,
the strategic goal was to secure the populace,
to make sure that the populace was safe.
Because once the populace was safe,
then it was,
okay,
now we're going to give you some food.
We're going to get some water.
We have Iraqi troops with us.
We,
so we worked all the time with Iraqi troops and they're speaking the same
language and it took a very short amount of time before that barrier got broken
down and the local populace of Ramadi turned against the insurgence because they
will no longer feared them.
And so that was the other huge tipping point was getting the,
the local populace of our,
of Ramadi on the side of the coalition.
Imagine that would give you a,
I mean,
an enormous informational advantage.
Absolutely the same.
It sounds like you have humility and openness to modifying preexisting
strategies.
Uh,
but then there's also an experimental piece.
It sounds like,
I mean,
how was,
how was the first,
uh,
experiment conducted or
how did it come to pass and be implemented,
uh,
that you had go in and occupy and test out that particular approach because it
seems like,
were there other,
uh,
experiments like that?
And I know I just asked two questions,
but,
uh,
I'm just trying to figure out in the military structure,
and I haven't been exposed to that where I'm sure there are a lot,
there's a,
there's a lot of command structures in place.
Um,
were you given a lot of latitude to experiment that way or did it require a lot
of process?
So let me give you a,
I'll try and give a concise answer.
It doesn't have it.
We can say this is your,
you know,
you're going deep right now.
Oh yeah.
Which is fine.
Uh,
because I guess it's your podcast.
So I'll take it back to a place called [inaudible] where the marines did a big
sweep through [inaudible].
And at some point when they went through alcaide EAM,
the local populace started saying,
hey,
there's bad guys over there.
Hey,
there's bad guys in that building down there.
Go get them too.
So there was a little thought about that.
Now,
there was a place in north of Ramadi called Talla far,
which there's a great,
uh,
legendary army commander and I'll have mcmasters and I got to look that up
because I think you're missing him.
Yeah,
that's okay.
And people in the show notes can also,
they can also do research master the guys,
legendary guy.
But he ran the C's clear and hold strategy up and tallow far and it was very
effective.
And again,
this is pre surge.
That was 2005,
2006 Colonel Mcfarland went and took over for him in California and saw,
you know,
got the turnover and understood what had happened.
And then Colonel Mcfarlane got the task once McMaster left to come down to
Ramadi and he said,
you know,
I'm going to do the same thing there.
And so that's what he did.
And you know,
it was,
you know,
one thing that's interesting is it's not a movie and so everything was not
perfect and you'd push into some of these neighborhoods and it was fierce,
fierce fighting and you know,
you take casualties.
And I think that current Mcfarland understood that deeply.
And he also had a vision for what the victory was going to look like.
So
those,
those pieces and,
and pushing in,
you know,
the first time it was like,
hey,
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to go into this neighborhood that's controlled by the insurgence and
move in
and in it,
in a,
in a battle such as,
uh,
you know,
Ramadi,
how do you define objectives,
um,
in the longer term,
not necessarily on a,
on a nightly basis,
but in the longer term,
so that you can focus the efforts and,
and sustain the morale for that matter.
Right?
And that's,
that's actually a simple question,
you know,
okay,
here's what we're going to do three days from now.
We're going to go into this neighborhood that we're going to establish a combat
outpost,
and that's what we're gonna focus on for the next three days.
And then once we get that thing established,
guess what?
We're to spend,
uh,
you know,
four or five days there and then we're going to do it again.
And grand picture,
you know,
strategic vision,
here's what it's gonna look like.
We're going to have combat outposts all over Ramadi that are going to be
controlled by Americans,
with Iraqi soldiers in them that can go out and talk to the local populous and
we can secure the city.
So it was,
it was a simple as that.
Now you take that down a level to let's say my seal platoon,
one of my seal platoons,
and they'd be saying,
okay,
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to go and take this particular building and then we're going to
cover for the conventional units as they come in in a very exposed way.
Because when you build these combat outposts,
your literally doing a construction project in the middle of a combat zone.
So these guys,
these brave army engineers are standing with,
you know,
a hammer in their hand,
full body armor and us,
you know,
reinforcing these buildings,
bloating,
sandbags,
building barricades,
and you know,
this is while we're being attacked.
Wow.
And so those guys,
you know,
like I said,
I can never give enough credit to the units that we work.
They're in Ramadi.
They were phenomenal and brave.
And what we would do is while they were doing those missions,
building out those combat outposts,
we would go out to the high ground surrounding the combat outpost.
So we'd sneak out into the areas surrounding the combat outpost.
So now when the enemy came to attack the combat outpost,
we would kill them,
right?
And they didn't know where we were in the beginning.
And eventually,
you know,
they'd figure out where we were and,
and come attack.
What,
um,
was the sort of division of expertise like among the 35 seals,
uh,
under your command in so much as,
and again,
I,
I have to apologize because my,
what I know of seals,
some of it has come from guys who have been deployed,
um,
who are friends of mine.
But a lot of it comes from seeing films,
right?
I mean,
it's,
it's a lot of the exposure that civilians have here.
But,
uh,
and some people say like,
Oh yeah,
that guy's a door kicker.
You know,
this guy's,
this,
this guy.
Is that,
how did the responsibilities break down across those 35,
you know,
it's,
it's a seal to seal platoons.
Each seal platoon has singular leader that's in charge of the whole platoon.
And then he's got some subordinate leadership underneath him.
And then you've got these guys that are,
have their specialty craft,
whether they're snipers,
whether their medic guys Korman,
whether they're breachers,
which are guys that blow up,
blow things up,
blow open doors,
a riflemen granted deers point men.
So you've got these various,
um,
skill sets in.
What's he say?
Uh,
I apologize.
The rifleman and then what was the other word?
Granted here are they're the same.
You know,
there's two different,
it depends,
you know,
so a rifleman is a guy with a rifle,
which we generally wouldn't have because almost every guy in a seal platoon is
doing something other than just shooting his gun.
Like I said,
he's a radio man,
so he's calling in for fire calling,
tanks,
calling,
casualty evacuation,
anything like that.
The sniper is being a sniper.
The machine gunners are machine gunners,
a granite dear lobs grant grenades at people.
Ah,
all right.
So,
so that's,
that's what a seal platoon is.
Now,
the experience level in the seagull platoon is,
you know,
you've got guys that have never deployed before and we had probably out of 30,
30,
whatever guys,
we probably had a dozen that had never deployed before.
So I was their first deployment to Iraq and it was,
you know,
pretty epic,
first deployment to Iraq.
Um,
and then you've got guys that have varying levels of experience inside the
platoons and you know,
some guys that deployed to Iraq one,
two or three times.
And that's probably the level of experience.
And did you have,
um,
what were the size of groups that would go out and say a,
a nightly rate or something like that?
And again,
I'm,
I apologize him playing the civilian role,
here are some,
I'm not going to get everything right,
but like what are the,
the,
the core group be sort of like a six or seven.
We were task organized depending on the mission.
So if it's important to remember that we were working with Iraqi forces,
so we had these other people with us,
sure.
That we could use as bodies to do,
you know,
some of what,
some of the work,
right?
Some of the work.
And so,
you know,
we'd send six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10 seals out with eight,
10,
12,
20,
40 Iraqis.
And then it's the whole spectrum because sometimes we'd send an entire seal
platoon out,
you know,
16 guys with 40 Iraqi soldiers or 50 Iraqi soldiers and sometimes we'd send,
five seals out with five Iraqi soldiers to do some kind of an Overwatch
position,
little smaller,
but we still had a minimum that we needed to take out.
What does an Overwatch position,
Overwatch position is kind of what I talked about earlier,
where you get the high ground or maybe not,
maybe not necessarily the high ground,
but often the high ground.
That's the tactical,
that's a tactical advantage is positioned on the battlefield,
is to be on the high ground.
Who are other people,
uh,
in the military,
alive or dead,
US or elsewhere,
who you really respect as a sort of strategists are tacticians
okay.
Obviously I talked about,
uh,
criminal,
Shawn Mcfarland,
who was just fantastic.
And,
you know,
he was,
and I don't know if I'm necessarily right on this,
but you know,
General Patraeus,
uh,
who wrote the manual on counterinsurgency.
So he's obvious and he orchestrated the surge and he's a brilliant,
and you know,
in my opinion was,
you know,
the critical player in,
in really turning the rest of the war.
Again,
we were pre surge and,
but I think they used the success in Ramadi as a reason to,
uh,
to sell the surge.
Like,
we can do this in other places.
We did it in Ramadi.
So,
you know,
from my perspective,
both those guys were,
uh,
or just outstanding.
And when you,
when you look at,
and the reason I was asking about the,
the smaller groups that are sent out,
say that the eight to 10 seals with then the,
uh,
the,
the Iraqi,
uh,
colleagues,
what distinguishes a good leader in that type of situation or in buds or
elsewhere?
I mean,
what,
what did,
what have you observed and learned about what makes a good leader versus a good
or mediocre or a bad leader?
Uh,
again,
it's,
it's the,
the immediate answer that comes to mind is humility because you've got to be
humble and you've got to be coachable.
You know,
that we would fire guys and later when I was running training,
we would fire a couple of leaders in every firm,
every seal team,
because they couldn't,
they couldn't lead.
And 99.9% of the time,
it was,
wasn't a question of their ability.
It was a question of their ability to listen and an ability to step outside and
see that maybe there's a better way to do things.
Uh,
so that's,
that's number one.
And number two,
I would say is a PR,
an individual who is balanced.
And you know,
I talk about there's a,
there's a phrase that I use.
It's the dichotomy of leadership.
So lead in a leadership situation,
you're constantly balancing these opposing forces.
So you have to be aggressive.
Absolutely.
Can you be too aggressive?
Yes,
you can.
Um,
can you be,
do you need to be courageous?
Yes you do.
Can you be foolhardy and get people killed?
Absolutely.
So there's all these balances.
Can you be too close to your men?
Yes you can.
Can you be not close enough?
Can you be too robotic?
Yes you can.
Can you be too emotional?
Absolutely.
So what I find the best leaders,
they have this ability to balance all those opposing forces.
And,
and usually when you do find a problem,
you know,
if you're,
if you're making,
if you realize that your leadership isn't working,
generally you can look and say,
oh,
I'm going too far in one direction on this particular,
uh,
force,
this dichotomy of leadership.
I'm going too far on being,
being overbearing.
I'm micromanaging.
Micromanaging is a great one,
right?
You can obviously micromanager your people and they won't act.
They won't do anything on their own.
They won't take any initiative.
And that's horrible.
The other end is you can not give them the guidance that they need and,
and not pay close enough attention to them.
And now they don't know what the mission is or what they're doing.
So there's all these dichotomies that you have to balance as a leader.
And you know,
I think that between being humble and,
and balancing all those dichotomies of leadership is,
is,
makes a good leader.
And how would say the ability to listen and be coachable?
Um,
what would be an example of how that manifests itself?
Just how you would observe that and say that's a guy who is good at
being humble and coachable or the opposite,
right?
Like,
so I'm looking for the things that you would observe or hear where he'd be like,
you know what?
I think we might have to let that guy go.
Yeah,
you'd see a guy in,
again,
now we're going back to training.
We put these guys through very,
um,
realistic and challenging training to say the least.
And I know if there's any guys that went through training when I was running it
right now,
they're chuckling because it was very realistic and psychotic and we put so much
pressure on these guys and overwhelm them.
And,
you know,
a good leader would come back and say,
I lost it.
I didn't control it.
I didn't,
I didn't do a good job.
I,
I didn't see what was happening.
I got too absorbed in this little tiny tactical situation that was right in
front of me.
They,
they either they'd make those criticisms themselves about themselves,
or they'd say,
what did I do wrong?
And when you told them,
they'd nod their head,
they'd pull out their notebook,
they'd take notes.
And,
and that right there,
you know,
that's a guy that's gonna that's gonna make it,
that's gonna do it right.
And then you get the guy that comes in and he's immediately saying,
uh,
you know,
you say,
well,
what'd you think of the operation?
Or if it was a disaster,
he said it was a disaster.
And you go,
well,
what went wrong?
And immediately it's,
well,
my assault team leader didn't do x and my mobility commander didn't do y.
And I told those guys I wanted them to go over there and they didn't go there.
Fingerpointing immediately finger pointing.
And that's just an,
an a telltale sign.
You've got a guy that's not humble enough and coachable and it's,
it's an awful thing.
And you can try and you can try and change people and sometimes they would
change,
but it's difficult to get them to change.
So,
you know,
that's,
some people are born with that characteristic and,
and it's,
it's a bummer to see because it's,
if you can't fix them,
you can't fix them.
Right.
And they're not going to listen to anybody.
Well it sounds like it's self awareness is also a big component of that.
To have the,
the awareness to kind of step outside and objectively evaluate yourself.
I,
you know,
I call it a detachment and you know,
that's one of the things that early on in my leadership career,
I actually remember when it happened.
I was probably 20 something years,
22 or 23 years old.
I was in my,
I was in my first seal platoon and we come up,
we're on an oil rig in California doing some training and we come up on this
level of this oil rig and it's never been an oil rig before.
They're very complex.
There's gear and boxes and just stuff everywhere on these levels.
And they're see through,
you can see through the floors and you can still,
it's complex environment.
And we come up and we all get on on this platform,
on this level,
and everybody freezes.
And I'm kind of waiting and I'm a new guy,
so I don't really,
you know,
I don't feel like I should be doing anything.
But then I said to myself,
you know,
somebody's got to do something.
So I just,
what's called high ported my gun.
So I just lifted my gun up towards the air,
like I'm not,
I'm not a shooter right now.
And I took one step back off the line and I looked around and I saw what the
picture was and I just said,
you know,
hold left,
move.
Right?
And,
and everybody heard it and they did it.
And I said to myself,
hmm,
you know,
there's that,
that that's what you need to do.
And so I realized that detaching yourself from the situation so you could
observe it so that you can see what's happening is absolutely critical.
And,
and now,
you know,
when I talked to executives or mid level managers,
I explained to them that I'm doing that all the time.
I,
it sounds horrible,
but it's almost like sometimes I'm not a participant in my own life.
I'm an observer of that guy that's doing it.
So if I'm having a conversation with you and you know,
we're trying to discuss a point and I'm watching and saying,
wait,
are you being too emotional right now?
Oh wait a second,
look at him.
He,
you,
cause I can't,
I'm not reading you correctly.
If I'm seeing you through my own emotion or ego,
I can't really see what you're thinking.
But if I step out of that and now I'm seeing,
I can see the real you.
And if you are getting angry,
if your ego is getting hurt,
if you're about to cave because you're just fed up with me.
Whereas if I'm raging in my own head,
I might miss all of that.
And so that detachment that takes place as a leader is critical.
And,
and you're 100% right on that.
How do you instill that or try to teach that?
Is that is,
is that something people,
because I feel like that may be more than the humility seems to be a coachable
skill.
Um,
and the part of the reason I say that is because I found that whether it's like
cognitive behavioral therapy or stoic philosophy for that matter,
you can in small increments conditioned people to have less of an extreme
emotional response and to try to observe themselves.
And I suppose that there's some Buddhists thought that would translate to that
as well,
but how do you teach?
How do you help teach someone that ability to detach?
So what we did to teach them was put them under extraordinary pressure,
were to fail to detach from the situation and step up and away from the problem
would result in failure.
And I had a great experience where one of my,
uh,
one of the,
the guy that actually took my job over as the troop commander and a very close
friend of mine,
he got hurt.
So he was,
he was going through the training now and I was running the training and we were
going out to a place called Niland,
California to do land warfare.
And again,
this is desert operations.
You're patrolling in long distances,
you're hitting targets.
And we have like high level laser tag guns that we use to shoot.
And,
and it's very,
we put a lot of pressure on people.
There's helicopters,
there's smoke,
there's bombs,
there's all kinds of stuff happening.
And this guy,
this buddy of mine,
he was supposed to be commanding at all,
but he had broken his neck.
Oh God.
About,
I don't know,
six weeks prior to this I said,
or like a ropes course or they always,
it was a climbing a ship and the guy above him fell and broke his neck.
And so this guy who's,
who had been in Ramadi with me and you know,
did an outstanding job and,
and amazing effort and was as brave as to a fault,
you know,
we're lucky he's here.
So he,
so,
so the land warfare training takes place and he comes out and I said,
hey,
just come out and watch with me.
And so he comes out and you know,
we're,
we're watching and we're out on one of these field training exercises.
So all this mayhem starts and there's bad guys up in the hills and there's bombs
going off and there's smoke everywhere.
And what from our position,
which we were standing next to the guys that were in it,
and he looks at me and he says,
you know,
it's so easy when you're not in it.
And I said,
this is how it was for me when we went through,
I was up here and he was like,
a light bulb went off,
you know,
he said,
I saw you,
you know,
like he would,
he kind of saw me like that and said,
how does he know what's happening?
So the ability easy in so much as when you're the outsider looking in,
you can see what to do,
what's going on.
Exactly.
And when you did it,
you were not necessarily physically removing yourself,
but sort of mentally.
Yes.
Pulling the perspective back so you could observe it.
So,
so if you take someone like your,
your uh,
your friend who has this realization like,
Oh holy shit.
Okay.
That explains a lot because if you could create this perspective,
you would have a huge tactical advantage.
Um,
what type of,
uh,
exercise would you put someone through where the consequences were so
significant that they would be forced to detach in that way?
I mean,
these are just exercise that we do and you know,
like I said,
so we would use lasers where this advanced laser tag system where you get,
you can get shot at 300 meters and if you go,
if you get shot at an island and your beeper goes off and says you're dead,
then you're dead right.
And you're going to have to get carried out by your buddies,
which is awful.
And you're going to get,
they're going to get hurt,
sprained ankles,
everything else.
It's a nightmare.
And then,
and they're also now they can't maneuver as well.
So now what happens when they get attacked again,
which they're going to,
because it's going to be Murphy's law there and the problems compound.
And if the leaders get bogged down in those problems and don't step back,
we will literally,
we would kill all
of them,
right?
And they'd come back with their,
with their heads down and say,
you know,
what the hell just happened and what can we do better?
And then,
you know,
we'd,
we'd have this talk with them.
And you know,
it's one of those things,
it's like when you,
it's like when you're growing up and you don't listen to anybody,
it was not that you don't listen to people,
but some lessons you have to learn,
you know,
through life and through experience.
And so that happened in the guys would,
you know,
guys at varying levels,
some of them would,
would be able to go,
oh,
I just saw it.
Okay,
now I can make this happen.
And that would happen as well.
Where I would see there,
you know,
when in like in Terminator when the beginning of the tournament,
I said,
you know,
on August 27th,
2016,
the machines became aware.
You could see their leadership switch happen and all of a sudden they'd go boom.
And then I would know my job was done and they'd step up.
They'd,
they'd,
they take a step back from the situation.
They would look around,
they'd observe,
they wouldn't,
they'd make good decisions and good calls and then watch them progress out of it
and finish the problem and,
and do well.
And then I knew that I had done my job.
That'd become aware that they became aware as leaders.
Yeah,
it sits.
So I,
um,
this is in my mind at least related to not panicking or at least being able to
think in the midst of panic.
Uh,
and there are so many examples of this man in sports and elsewhere,
but I remember doing some,
uh,
convoy and evasive driving training with a bunch of executive types.
I mean,
these are not military guys.
Uh,
just really for the experience and part of the training involved,
splitting up into two teams,
having sort of an ambush team and trying to go get a broken down car with a
person passed out inside,
they might be dead that might be passed out back through uh,
basically a a finish line and we got to pick teams and I happened to be I guess
one,
one team leader and I picked the guy who had the best evasive driving skills to
be sort of the victor one driver.
And then I was in the passenger side with cubs and everybody had paintball guns
and uh,
we had to keep the passenger side and drivers had windows down so we could get
nailed.
And uh,
there are also drivers trying to like take us off the road and whatnot.
In any case,
it's soon as the paint ball started flying,
this guy just gunned it in a straight line,
no response to comms,
no response to anything.
Even though under the pressure of sort of mock competition with the evasive
driving and so on within Cohen's,
he'd been spectacular.
How do you either pick people who are less likely to have that,
that just go into a blind kind of red zone where they're unresponsive,
uh,
or,
prepare people and condition them so they can actually function when the shit
starts hitting the fan.
And then that's exactly right what you just said.
We
desensitize them to being in horrible situations and we condition them and work
with,
keep putting that pressure on them until they can get through it.
Got It.
So it's just a matter of exposure.
And most,
most guys do,
you know,
most,
most guys,
they go,
okay,
I'm used to this.
And then,
and then it'll be up a level eight for real.
It'll be up a level.
So you'll and most guys will be good there too.
You'll have a couple of fallout there,
but uh,
but the seal teams does a very good job of applying that pressure and
conditioning you in desensitizing you to horrible situations so that you can
deal with it when it comes.
Uh,
so I want to talk a little bit,
we're just going to shift gears a little bit and I know we're,
we're going to bounce around a lot,
but,
so I,
I have,
uh,
I've heard that I've heard of your workouts,
when you're deployed,
and one guy said,
I don't know if this is true that you would,
uh,
you know,
roll with like 20 guys in a platoon as,
as a workout and just tap out like 20 guys.
Is that true?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
you're own with guys that don't know anything.
And so in order to get good training in,
I would just have guys,
you know,
come in,
every 15 minutes.
And,
you know,
I,
I remember this particular year when I was at team too,
and I'll just have the guys come in every 15 or 20 minutes and just,
you know,
roll with them and then another guy would come in.
So,
yeah,
it's tough,
but I mean,
I was,
you know,
better than them at Jujitsu.
And so it's not that I was any tougher,
I just knew more.
When you look at,
uh,
of course,
you know,
many very good competitors in Jujitsu,
MMA.
When you look at the,
the top performers in that world,
and then some of the top performers you've met in the CEO World,
uh,
what are the commonalities,
if any?
Well,
let me talk about Jujitsu first.
Sure.
Uh,
one thing I noticed about Jujitsu is there are,
when we get to that,
when he gets to the world class level of Jujitsu guys,
there is a stratification there between guys that have a natural God given
ability that is above and beyond normal human.
It's above and beyond what a normal human being would do or should be able to
do.
Right?
And there's not many of those people who loves you,
put,
who comes to mind when you think of that?
I,
I think,
um,
Hixon Gracie who,
who,
you know,
I've trained with him and yeah,
he's,
I was,
I was a blue belt when I trained with them,
but you could feel that this guy is not normal.
Uh,
Dean Lester,
who was my training partner forever.
And you know,
I've rolled with,
Gosh from all over the world and dean lister is at another level.
I've never worked with Marcello Garcia,
but,
uh,
you know,
just from watching you and competition,
you can see that he has that as well.
And then the next,
and,
and I mean,
that's,
there's not a large group of people at that level.
And then the next level down is guys that trained like maniacs and they're great
athletes and that's that.
And they're awesome to,
you know,
those guys are the world champions,
et cetera.
Um,
so that's,
that's my estimation.
And having rolled with guys on both ends of the spectrum,
you know,
Dean as an example,
because Dean
has won world championships training a minuscule amount compared to,
you know,
what a normal person would have to train to get there,
which I don't know if that's a compliment or,
uh,
us,
you know,
a negative.
Right.
But you know,
it's,
it's true.
Yeah.
It's a now in the seal teams as far as the,
the high performers,
I think it's the people that,
you know,
you,
it's a certain level of focus I think.
And again,
a certain level of open mindedness and a certain level of dedication to the task
and to the craft that they're dealing with.
And you get guys that are just super passionate about the job.
And if you're super passionate about the job in the seal teams,
there is a really good chance you're going to be one of the top performers
because you're gonna put in all that extra effort to do well.
What are you world class at that people might not realize?
Uh,
well,
first of all,
I think worldclass is a,
is a strong word.
It's a stroller.
I get to,
I sorry to interrupt because I,
because I'd say I'm worldclass at,
uh,
you know,
just about nothing.
Um,
and,
and as far as what people might not know about me,
one thing that's interesting about me is I live a fairly compartmentalized life
where,
you know,
my Jujitsu friends would not meet my seal friends who would not meet the people
that I work with in a leadership situation or in a,
in a civilian sector business world.
So there's people that don't know that,
you know,
I'm a really good Jujitsu player or that I work with big companies and help
their leadership.
And so there's that.
But if I had to say,
you know what,
uh,
the skill set that I have that I think helped me was number one,
taking complex things and making them simple and then being able to communicate
that simplicity to other people is number one.
And number two,
the ability that we already talked about to detach myself from situations
emotionally and mentally,
usually not physically.
You have to be able to do it without detaching physically.
But those,
those things would be what I would say my talents if I had any.
Because,
you know,
I'm definitely not the fastest,
not the strongest,
not the,
uh,
not the most flexible or whatever and not the smartest,
but it seems like,
um,
it's very interesting when Madonna would say the same thing about,
like,
I'm not the best answer,
I'm not the best singer.
I'm not the best this,
but I think like yourself,
she's kind of a,
um,
what a five tool player,
like a baseball player who can like hit for power,
hit for getting on base,
could field,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I mean,
and it's the collection of those tools that makes you say are worldclass
commander or something like that.
Uh,
what is your,
what do,
what do your morning routines look like on an ideal day?
Like what does the first 90 minutes of your day look like?
When do you wake up?
What does,
what does that look like?
So I wake up early,
I wake up at four 45.
Um,
I like to have that psychological win over the enemy.
And you know,
for me that when I wake up in the morning and I don't know why I'm thinking
about the enemy and what they're doing,
and I know I'm not active duty anymore,
but it's still in there,
that there's a guy that's in a cave somewhere and he's rocking back and forth
and he's
got a machine gun in one hand and a,
and a grenade in the other hand.
And he's waiting for me and we're going to meet.
And when I wake up in the morning,
I'm thinking to myself,
what can I do to be ready for that moment which is coming,
which is coming.
And uh,
so that,
that propels me out of bed.
That,
and I work out early in the morning,
uh,
she wake up at four 45.
What's the next thing?
Aside from like brushing your teeth and doing the usual,
uh,
do the usual start working out.
And I try,
ideally I'd like to get done with my workout by the time the sun comes up.
And so now if there's waves,
you know,
I live by the Ocean Salt,
go surfing and get done with that.
And what is the morning work out?
Well,
what does a typical morning workout look like?
Uh,
I,
you know,
I do a lot of pull ups,
pushups in depths I dead lift and do squats.
I do sprints.
I mean it's everything that everybody knows.
It's everything that everybody does,
right?
I swinging kettle bells,
uh,
do burpees,
you know,
it's,
it's all that and it's like a 60 minute workout.
How long has,
it depends.
It depends on what's going on.
Um,
I will,
I'll try and do some strength movements to be strong,
you know,
dead lifts,
cleans,
clean and jerk,
something like that.
Uh,
to make myself stronger.
Or even if it's,
even if it's something like just dead hang pullups and I'm just maxing out,
but I'll do like that to make myself stronger.
And sometimes that can take awhile,
you know,
cause I'll just want to relax and,
hit singles or doubles.
I'm on dead lifts or cleans or whatever.
And then when I get done with that,
I'll do some kind of,
uh,
some kind of metabolic conditioning of some kind.
You know,
I'll be sprinting or rowing or swinging a kettle bell or you know,
lighter weight clean and jerks for wraps or something like that.
So that's what it looks like for me.
So you finish training when the sun comes up,
hit the waves,
since they're there,
which is a good policy and,
um,
what happens then,
you know,
I'll come back and,
start doing normal human stuff.
Right?
That's one of the work.
But you know,
I,
you know,
I have,
I have a leadership and management consulting business,
so I'll have clients to talk to all of emails to push out,
um,
and,
and I'll,
I'll start taking care of that business.
I normally don't get hungry until 10 or 11 o'clock in the morning,
so around 10 or 11 o'clock I start wanting,
you know,
to start to graze on some food and I'll do that.
And then by,
by noon I'm,
I'm feeling pretty hungry.
Like I need some lunch.
And,
uh,
what is,
what is your diet generally look like?
January looks like steak,
steak and chicken and salad.
Paleo Ish.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And um,
I don't know.
You know,
I'm no stranger to having some mint chocolate chip ice cream or some oval teen
or whatever.
Uh,
you know,
again,
I'm not,
you know,
a competitive bodybuilder.
And so,
you know,
I,
I'll eat some normal food,
right?
You can indulge when the,
when the,
when the spirit moves you,
when you think of the word successful,
who are the first people or the first person that comes to mind?
So for me,
you know,
the,
the part of the world that I've seen is a very dark place.
It's a dark place.
That's what war is.
And when your job,
which my job was,
was to expand that darkness in many ways.
I mean,
it's,
war is about killing people.
And so for me,
when I look to someone that's successful,
it's someone that brings some light into that darkness.
So for me,
the first people that come to my head are Mark Lee,
who is one of my guys first seal killed in Iraq.
Mike Monster,
one of my guys,
second seal killed in Iraq,
posthumously awarded the Medal of honor and Ryan Job,
one of my guys wounded in Iraq,
blind in both eyes,
made it home,
medically retired from the,
from the navy,
married his high school sweetheart,
got her pregnant and
finished his college degree.
And after his 22nd surgery to repair the damage that was done to his,
his head and face,
there were complications and he died as well.
But all of those guys
in all that darkness,
they did things.
They made a sacrifice
that
was completely selfless.
And to do that
and to live
and fight and die
like a warrior,
that to me is success.
And those guys
are my heroes.
What do you,
what do you struggle with?
And I asked that because I mean,
we've,
we've only just met,
but it's hard for me as a civilian to fathom what,
what you and your friends had been through,
uh,
impossible for me to find them.
Um,
and I mean,
it makes me just feel ashamed for ever complaining about a bad day or a hard
day.
Uh,
given what you guys have experienced in the stakes that are involved and the
sacrifices and the sadness and tragedy that is a part of that job.
Uh,
what,
what do you struggle with,
uh,
whether it's in the business sphere or just in life in general,
if you're open to talking about it?
Because I certainly,
I know that
I used to,
when I had these icons in my head,
I was like,
oh my God,
Richard Branson,
he's got it all figured out.
He's doing everything perfectly.
He's just,
he's on cruise control,
hitting home runs every time he gets it bad.
And as I've slowly gotten to known,
honestly,
Branson directly,
although I have met him before,
I realized like people all have,
and this is something that you talked about the detachment.
You know,
when I find myself,
I've always had kind of impatience and anger issues and it's helped me to be in
sport
and in business and in a negotiation,
but it's also caused some problems for me.
And,
uh,
but I've realized that one of the ways I can tone that down is by realizing that
like everybody has,
everyone is fighting a battle,
you know,
nothing about,
uh,
in some way.
But what are the things that,
uh,
that you find difficult or that you struggle with or have struggled with?
It's,
it's,
it's an interesting question because,
and this is a filler answer in case you couldn't tell that because when I start
off with,
it's an interesting question and that means I'm not really quite sure what to
say.
Um,
I've,
you know,
I've been,
I've been lucky,
I've been blessed.
I've had,
you know,
a life that I would not trade with anyone in the world.
Um,
when you talk about Ramadi,
I,
that was the highlight of my life because I was leading men in combat,
which is something which was something that I always wanted to do and something
that I felt that I was destined to do.
And when I was in that situation,
I knew that I wasn't,
I don't look back and say,
Oh,
I wish I would have enjoyed that.
No,
I knew it then.
This is it.
This is,
this is what you have been waiting for your whole life and what you really have
been preparing for your whole life.
And I was lucky to be there and I was lucky to have incredible guys to work
with,
both in my unit and in the other units in the army and the Marine Corps that we
work with.
I was lucky enough to have guys that were so brave and so dedicated,
and I will use the word fearless,
not that they didn't have fear,
but that they overcame it all the time.
And so I'd say if there's anything that I struggle with now,
it's just that,
does anything else matter?
Is there in the answer's no.
The answer's no.
Nothing else matters.
Nothing else is close.
And so you have to deal with that.
And,
and I don't,
struggle is a strong word because I don't sit there at night,
you know,
wishing I was back while.
Okay.
I do do that.
You know,
sometimes I,
I often wish I was back,
but I don't dwell on it because it's gone and I'm so happy that I could be part
of it and that I was able to work with such tremendous guys and,
uh,
I try and keep their memory alive every day in my own head.
How did you,
when you were
reconcile the risks that are inherent in that job with family,
with your family?
Well,
first of all,
I actually,
when I had,
when I was young,
you know,
I thought that I was going to die.
I thought I was gonna die in combat.
There was no war going on.
This is ignorant thought,
right?
This is young,
stupid,
um,
you know,
ah,
unknowledgeable idiot saying I'm only going to live to be,
I'll never going to make it to 30.
Right.
And I was good with that because I had nothing.
I was a single guy that was,
uh,
wanted to go out and destroy the world,
you know?
That's awesome.
Then,
you know,
as I got older and I realized though,
I'm actually going to live to be 30 and probably 40.
And so I had to,
you know,
work through that.
Um,
and you know what?
I got married along the way had kids and I actually,
when I had kids,
I actually felt more ready to die because,
you know,
I had left my fulfill that.
I just filled my,
my,
I left the,
I left children.
And so I actually felt like I was okay with that.
Um,
which I guess that's bad,
but you know,
men have been traveling and fighting for thousands and thousands of years since
the beginning of mankind.
And I knew that as a warrior,
that's okay.
And sometimes men don't come home and the family's drive on and that's the way
the world works.
So I didn't really have much to reconcile there.
Um,
now as far as division of time and you know,
having a family,
I can tell you,
uh,
you know,
I was very lopsided and unbalanced in that situation.
You know,
I,
the seal teams to me was everything and nothing else mattered.
Well,
I shouldn't say it didn't matter,
but it was definitely on a much lower priority.
And I remember actually my wife sent me an email when I was on deployment and
she,
you know,
she's very independent doing her thing and she sends me an email that says
something along the lines of,
hey,
you know,
send us a picture of where you sleep.
Fair enough.
You know,
they show the kids were when I sleep at night.
And so I went up to my room and we had some old,
uh,
Saddam palace that we had taken over,
not really palace Saddam House that we had taken over.
And that's where we lived.
And I had the one of the rooms in this building.
And so I went up and I took some pictures,
some digital pictures of my bed,
and I looked at him and I said,
oh,
wait a second.
And I went into all folder that I had and I pulled it out and I took out
pictures of my wife and kids and I hung them up on the wall and I took pictures
and I sent those home and I took the pictures back down because
I didn't want to be thinking about my wife and kids when I had men's lives at
stake.
And
that's how I compartmentalized and did what I did,
what I had to do,
which was be dedicated to my guys,
to the mission and to the country.
And at that point in time,
you know,
it had to take priority over everything took priority over there.
I mean,
my guys,
they had families,
they had to go home too.
I can't be thinking about this other stuff.
So there's a little reconciliation.
Who are,
uh,
now that you've entered the,
the civilian world,
are there particular nonmilitary leaders,
whether they're CEOs or maybe outside of the private sector,
uh,
you admire or
look to in some way as role models?
You know,
you meet these guys and girls and they are,
a lot of them might as well have been in the seal teams.
You know,
they're aggressive,
they're making things happen.
And yeah,
I'll,
I admire and learn from them all the time,
you know,
and,
and I think they get the same thing for me.
And that's why I'm in business,
you know?
So,
uh,
absolutely.
There's some,
you know,
America's the greatest country on earth and you know,
capitalism is what makes this country one of the,
one of the things that makes this country so great and those folks that run
these businesses are,
you know,
part of that fabric that makes America great.
So,
absolutely there,
they're incredible people and,
and they have the same faults that seals have and,
and they make the same mistakes and they get,
they get involved emotionally with stuff and their ego gets in the way,
of course,
just like it happens with seals,
it happens with them.
And,
and they,
you know,
they make the same mistakes where they don't explain the mission to their troops
or they don't break it down from a strategic level to a tactical level so that
people on the frontline can understand.
So it's all the same mistakes.
And that's again,
that's kind of why we're in business now.
Right.
Humans will be humans.
Exactly.
Unfortunately.
Yes.
That is correct.
And you know,
when you,
when you were talking about,
um,
the detachment,
it made me think of,
uh,
quite a few years ago,
but I had my first sort of frivolous lawsuits come in,
which completely paralyze me.
I mean,
I was so intimidated and shocked and fearful and it ended up getting completely
tossed out.
But it took a long time and a lot of money.
And I ended up developing migraines.
I started clenching my jaw to the point where these shooting pains and I had to
get a mouthpiece in it.
It caused a whole cascade of health problems and issues.
And I remember talking to a number of my buddies who had been in business for
decades and at very high levels.
And one of them,
I won't give his full name,
where Pete,
really hilarious,
uh,
but brilliantly effective executive.
He goes,
Timmy,
he's like,
you're too fucking nice.
I should have sued you just because you should get used to it.
And he's like,
starts talking to me,
treating it like such a non event.
It was just such a nonevent for him and I couldn't compute it at the time.
But,
uh,
now I've just realized like some of these things are a cost of doing business
and if you're going to be aggressive and push the envelope and step into
environments that are uncertain because that's where a lot of rewards are,
potentially you're going to deal with these things.
And so now I'm at a point like I've been exposed to that enough times,
didn't not necessarily frivolous lawsuits,
but just legal headaches because that's a sort of a side effect of having a very
vigorous free market,
uh,
on one hand is you,
you have some legal complications.
And,
uh,
what I've tried to figure out for myself,
spending time with people who have been deployed and done the realistic training
that you've referred to.
I mean,
some of which is just beyond intense,
uh,
as they've described it to me.
I've wanted to
take myself out of this sort of keyboard,
uh,
shackled experience from day to day and expose myself to more of these stresses
to try to toughen myself and inoculate myself against future uncertainty and
things like that.
What are,
uh,
what are skills or experiences that you think every man should have?
No,
I mean,
there's a whole lot,
there's a whole list of those.
Oh yeah,
no,
I'm,
I'm interested because quite frankly,
I feel like,
and I've had female friends say this to me where they're like,
you know,
okay,
I meet a lot of guys.
Like I date a lot of guys,
but there just aren't many men out there anymore,
which that we could dig really far into that.
And there's,
there's all sorts of complicated sort of gender questions and topics to that
could raise.
But just putting all that aside for the time being,
I think a lot of folks like myself,
even,
uh,
and I experienced this when I was doing the four hour chef and really got back
into doing hunting and feel dressing and trying to build things and working with
fire and I was like,
wow,
I feel like I'm slowly becoming maybe barely manually literate,
you know,
compared to like my great grandfather who was chopping wood every day,
building stuff,
fixing things that broke,
et cetera.
Um,
so what's,
what would be on that list in your mind?
I mean,
if guys are listening to this and you knew it,
I want to toughen the fuck up just still,
just a little bit.
You know,
you,
if you went bare bones basic,
you're talking food,
shelter and water,
right?
Do you have the skills to bring those things to the table and make them happen?
I think that's a very basic place to start.
I can tell you that from,
from my
perspective.
And I actually gave a speech at one of my buddies weddings and you know,
I said that there was three things in my life that made me feel like a man.
And when you,
when I say feel like a man,
it doesn't mean blow up and feel like a man.
It actually means the opposite actually means I'm confident enough that I don't
need to bow up and I don't need meaning puff up your chest,
puff up my chest and I'm a bad ass.
Yeah.
And the first one was,
that was actually a Jujitsu was learning how to fight and knowing that there's
not a question that if I get into an altercation I can handle myself.
I 100% that.
Cause when you're,
when you don't know Jujitsu or you don't know how to fight,
then you questioned that in the back of your mind.
And how do you,
how do you answer that question?
You act like an Asshole,
right?
You,
these are the guys that run around in a bar getting in fights with people.
Cause they don't know.
They don't,
they're not confident that they can handle themselves.
So that was number one.
Number two was going into combat because again,
there was a big question mark of view,
don't know for sure how you're going to react in those situations.
And I felt pretty good that I knew how it was going to act,
but you know,
you need to,
you need to check the box.
And so I checked that box and I knew that I was going to do fine and that I did
find in that I was brave and not scared and was able to detach myself and make
decisions and make things happen.
So that was good.
And then the last one was getting married and having kids because now all of a
sudden I have other humans that are directly relying on me for as their,
you know,
their soul kind of leader and you know,
realizing that this is the most important thing.
You have to make this the most important thing in your life.
And you're out of that game too,
you know,
so you're no longer trying to do them.
You're no longer trying to impress,
you know,
a girl or whatever because you got a girl.
Right?
And so there's a,
there's a level of,
you know,
I don't care anymore,
that that is also nice.
So those,
those three things were for me were kind of the,
where I was able to say,
okay,
you know,
I'm good now,
let's focus on being a good,
a good guy and moving forward.
But those were,
those are,
those are three good ones.
The,
the on the Jujitsu side,
I,
that's the only one that I can,
that I can speak to having done,
uh,
you know,
a little bit here and there and also Moy Thai and whatnot.
But I think that it's,
it's so valuable on so many levels because not only do,
you know,
you can handle yourself,
but if you think you're a tough guy and you go to a good gym,
you get taught really quickly how uncuff you are.
And so,
uh,
I just remember for instance as training
at fair tax ages ago here in San Francisco and,
um,
you know,
one of the guys who was a trainer,
his name is n e n,
n and he's a southpaw.
So I trained with them because I'm a south pump,
the most unassuming little dude you've ever seen in your life.
Calves,
the size of my torso,
but otherwise you would never guess in a million years.
And he had terrible fashion sense.
And so you'd wear these like huge baseball caps.
It would cover his entire head.
So he looked like he was about seven years old.
It was our ears,
only,
like five foot,
one,
five foot,
two huge baggy tee shirt,
baggy pants.
So he just looked like average guy who's going to be some type of manual labor,
uh,
and people have mistaken for being Mexican.
And I just remember he went out to this bar because the gym was on Clementine
history,
which was between Howard and folsum I think around.
No,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
it was between Howard and folsum between fifth and six,
which is a,
it was a terrible place to be when,
when,
um,
when I was training there,
in fact Alex Gong,
the owner was shot in the chest and killed,
um,
basically while I was there and uh,
by guy stuck in traffic.
It's an insane story.
But suffice to say that he goes out to a bar and I was at a fly in camp at the
time with a bunch of other guys and this guy pulls a knife on one of the other
trainers.
Why?
Who knows?
And so everybody kind of backs up and they're like kind of two groups facing
each other.
And one of the guys is like,
I'm gonna fuck you up.
And to end who looks like he's like a tiny little guy and he just throws the
nastiest roundhouse kick you can imagine,
basically breaks the guy in half.
Like it's a lego figure being broken by gorilla.
And then that was just the show stopper.
But it's just,
I think once you train with people like that,
you're like,
I am never going to pick a fight because you never know who theN is.
Right.
And,
um,
and I,
I think it's very,
uh,
it,
it also that confidence and that humility I think transfers to so many other
areas,
uh,
because you realize like,
wow,
you know,
I thought I was the cat's meow.
I thought I was the king of the hill and in Areas A,
B,
c,
d or e,
but you know what,
that's probably not the case.
Um,
the,
uh,
on the combat side of things,
what are stressful experiences that a civilian might expose themselves to that
could,
I know,
not perfectly simulate it,
but to perhaps give them that type of fear,
inoculation or conditioning on some level.
Um,
I think any of those,
you know,
rock climbing,
parachuting,
uh,
anything that has a real,
real danger to it,
which both those things can,
you know,
and do.
Um,
I think those,
those can definitely help.
I would say those are,
those are people good exemption that we could sit here and brainstorm about it.
You know,
cause,
cause as soon as you put simulation,
you know,
we could say paint ball,
right,
right.
But,
but there's no risk
risk and paintball,
they're just to zero.
So it's cool.
And you can definitely get somewhat conditioned to,
you know,
that,
that panic and that stress level,
cause it hurts.
You get hit with a paint ball,
you know,
owl,
owl.
But it's not,
it's not the fear of death,
which the fear of death is the,
uh,
is I guess the,
the real,
the real thing that we're talking about.
And I guess you overcome that fear of death
and then what else was there to be afraid of now?
Right.
You know,
well,
you and I were,
uh,
you know,
we were sitting here where my house,
and you notice the Musashi that I have out over there,
this,
this historical novel about,
uh,
Miyamoto Musashi.
And I,
I think that,
um,
I don't know where it came from and I can't really pinpoint it.
But,
uh,
the reason I have that there is to remind me that if you're constantly afraid of
death,
I mean,
you're paralyzed in so many facets of your life.
It really prohibits you from making even effective decisions,
right?
So one could say,
well,
you should love your family and have the photos up.
And it's like,
well,
if I really want to love my family and go home to see my family,
maybe I shouldn't have those up as something that's going to occupy a part of my
brain.
I need to be effective in the field for me and my men.
Right?
No doubt about it.
So it's thinking not about that first move that looks good on paper and to
everyone around you.
But thinking about the second,
the tertiary effect,
etc.
Um,
do you have,
um,
are there any books that you've gifted to other people?
Uh,
uh,
or,
or what,
what do you gift to someone?
So for books,
there's,
I think there's only one book that I've ever given and have only given it to a
couple people.
Uh,
then that's a book called about face by Colonel David Hackworth.
And it is huge.
Have you ever heard of it?
I haven't.
And uh,
I was just looking for it.
Oh wait,
here's my,
here's my pad.
And,
and interestingly,
I looked for it today on,
on to see if I could download a digital copy and I don't think it's available
digital,
which surprised me.
So Colonel David Hackworth was the tail end of World War II.
Uh,
he was in Korea,
he was highly decorated in Korea.
He joined the,
like joined the merchant marines or something when he was 15 and got into the
army when again,
right after World War II.
So he kind of got raised by those World War II veterans.
And then he was in Korea and he was in Vietnam.
And he was just absolutely
borderline worshiped by the men that he led and by some of the senior leadership
and just a great book.
And he was a rebel,
you know,
and,
and he did question the way we were doing things.
And what's controversial about him is that he's the guy that said to Walter
Cronkite,
or he said that he,
he's the first guy in Vietnam that said you were not going to win this thing.
And so he's kind of,
you know,
blacklisted by much of the army.
But you know,
as you dig into that,
what he was really saying was,
we're not going to win this thing if we keep fighting how we're fighting.
He recognized that we needed to do a significant paradigm shift in the strategy
that we were executing over there.
And you know,
it's like you,
you've heard,
hey,
we've never lost,
we never lost a tactical battle in Vietnam.
You've heard that,
right?
Yep.
And there's plenty of people that will say that all day long.
But if you and I are leading a platoon and we take our platoon out and we hit a
booby trap and it kills three of our guys are two of our guys and wounds and
other three and there's no one to shoot at.
And we met evac those guys,
and we come back to base who,
who won,
who won that,
right?
And you know,
he recognized that.
So the metrics that were being used were sort of a,
not a lot a smokescreen,
but they were at,
at best the wrong metrics and ionic kids.
I had that book next to my bed in Ramadi and I literally read it every night.
I would,
you know,
that's how it fall asleep.
I'd go read a couple of pages,
you know,
just open to any and you'd find something in every,
it was very comparable.
You know,
they were working with the,
the South Vietnamese army and guess what?
They were corrupt and they were scared and they weren't the best soldiers.
And we were working with Iraqis and guess what?
They were corrupt and they were scared and they weren't the best.
There were so many parallels between the two.
And so that's the book that I've given to some,
a couple of close friends of mine that,
that,
you know,
I wanted them to have about face.
The other book that I really,
that the,
the,
the other book that I've read multiple times is blood meridian.
Blood Meridian.
Yeah.
I don't know that.
Oh,
okay.
So it's written by Cormac Mccarthy.
Oh,
fantastic writers.
So this is his best book.
And you know,
I was an English major in college and so,
you know,
I was forced to read all kinds of books.
And you know,
obviously Shakespeare is,
is,
is kind of the pinnacle in my mind.
And this Cormac McCarthy is the guy that I think it actually has that.
And if you read blood Meridian,
then there it is.
Right.
And I think what I find so
gripping about it is,
you know,
I talked earlier about the darkness of the world,
and this is a historical novel based on a group called the Glanton gang that
were killing Indians.
And they ended up killing everybody.
Uh,
if you had black hair,
your scalp was going to be taken.
And that's what it's about.
And it's completely epic and,
but it,
but for me,
it showed,
it communicated to me the a Guy Cormac Mccarthy was able to show the in
humanity.
And there's nothing good about that.
I mean,
there's nothing pleasant in any way,
shape or form in that book.
But that's in many ways the world that I lived in.
Do you think there is,
I,
I struggled with this myself because apart and when I say struggle with what am
I struggling with,
how much to voluntarily expose myself to darkness because I have sort of ups and
downs that I contend with and a lot of people in my family just hereditarily
deal with this.
But I feel like on one hand,
I don't want to be Pollyanna ish.
I don't want to,
I don't want to just put on my rose colored glasses and believe that everything
is okay.
Everyone has everyone else's best interests in mind,
right?
Because I've had friends who had been kidnapped.
Um,
I've had,
uh,
nothing that compares to what you've experienced,
but I've seen enough glimpses of this like brutish,
um,
nastiness that on,
on one hand,
you know,
I wonder as a civilian,
should I not look at that stuff?
Should I,
should I try to shield myself,
you know,
develop a basic level of protection and,
and skills,
but otherwise shield myself from it because it's not my job to have to look that
in the face.
And in fact,
it will darken my view of humanity or should I really like stare it directly in
the eyes and recognize it for what it is and become acquainted with it.
And I don't know why I think about this as much as I do.
Maybe it's because I have enough friends who've been in the military that it's,
it's sometimes a topic of conversation.
But what are your thoughts?
I think that in order to truly experience the light and the bright,
you have to see the darkness.
And I think if you shield yourself from the darkness,
you'll not appreciate and fully understand the beauty,
the beauty of life.
And again,
you know,
I go back to the sacrifices that I saw guys make on the battlefield and it's in
the complete darkness of the world of the human soul.
And you see that there's no,
there's no nothing brighter than somebody that lays down their life for their
friends.
And so I think if you want to understand the beauty and the glory of the life
you have,
it is good to know and understand that darkness.
Now that makes sense.
What are,
what are common myths?
What are some of the most common misconceptions about,
um,
navy seals
or you can pick whichever one you want to tackle.
Um,
what,
um,
inaccuracy is bother you about seals
or the military for that matter that are common in movies?
One of the things that I,
that I talk about when I talk to businesses because businesses think that,
um,
you know,
if you're a military guy,
if,
if you're,
if Tim is military guy and I outrank you and I tell you to go do something,
you're going to go do it with a big smile on your face and you're going to make
it happen.
And so that's the,
that's the misconception.
And if that was true,
then military leadership would be the easiest form of leadership in the world
because everyone would just obey your commands,
right?
And it couldn't be further from the truth.
Now it would work if I outrank you and I tell you to clean the toilet,
you go,
okay,
you outrank me and you go do it.
But then you multiply the intensity.
There are times infinite to where I'm telling you you need to go charge your
machine gun nest and you're going to die if you do it.
Are you gonna listen to me?
I wouldn't want to you.
You wouldn't want to and you may or may not,
right?
You may or may not.
And I need to be a leader.
I need to actually be a leader too.
If I'm going to get you to do stuff,
I need to lead you.
I can't just order you to do it.
So that's the biggest misconception is that,
oh,
if we're in the military and our order you to do something,
you're going to have to do it.
Now again,
you're not going to disobey the chain of command.
But you know there's stories of seals.
If you don't have so many stories from seals and Vietnam that have told me,
Oh,
they got tasked with a mission to go out and do x,
and they looked at the mission and said,
you know what,
that doesn't make any sense.
I'll tell you what,
we'll,
they'd go out,
they'd go out on patrol 100 yards out outside the wire,
sit down in a little,
a little rice patty somewhere,
wait two hours,
come back and say,
yeah,
the target wasn't there or the ambush didn't happen or whatever.
They would just blatantly disobey.
Those are not blatantly,
they would surreptitiously,
yes,
surreptitiously disobey orders.
So that's,
that's one of the,
one of the big challenges,
the,
another thing I'll get is,
you know,
I'll meet with a CEO and he'll say,
I,
you know,
I can't wait for you to get in here and whip my people into shape.
So you know,
in their mind they're thinking that if I come in and yell and scream,
people do pushups,
like a drill instructor,
that that will somehow,
you know,
create a paradigm shift in the strategy and the culture of the company.
We both can laugh at that because it's completely false.
And you know,
I think it,
it comes very quickly as I start to talk to them about what's happening inside
their company.
They realize that,
you know,
what we do from a leadership perspective is infinitely more about brains than it
is about brawn.
And the Brown stuff is from the movies and it does not work in reality.
What,
uh,
when,
when you mentioned the,
the seals in Vietnam,
you know,
sitting right outside the trip wires or whatnot,
maybe think of band of brothers,
uh,
towards the end.
Um,
I don't know what your opinion is of that,
um,
that entire series,
but awesome.
I've,
I've watched it multiple times.
My mom,
I grew up,
my mom is very fascinated by World War II,
so
letters from you what Gima and so on to sh.
So that fascination was passed onto me.
Hardcore history is an amazing podcast for listening to,
whether it's world war one or Gaviscon or otherwise,
but that's I completely second that.
Oh,
it's so good.
I tell people about it all the time.
Yeah.
Dan Carlin's amazing.
Uh,
but in,
in of brothers,
you know,
they,
they were tasked with,
I guess a raid towards the end.
It's like,
we've,
we've already won this and this is for some type of God.
Is this for somebody who wants a promotion back thousands of miles away.
And so they made the decision,
you know,
to kind of sit it out.
Uh,
I dunno why I felt compelled to share that.
I just,
I think,
I think the band of brothers for me more than anything else that I've observed
gave me,
I felt like I had a window into sort of the pain and suffering and courage and
sacrifice that was involved,
uh,
in a battle that I,
that is,
I suppose in many ways,
very,
very different from the insurgent,
uh,
sort of counterinsurgency warfare in terms of terrain.
Right.
I mean,
when you have a bad guy late like Hitler,
it seems like in retrospect everyone's on your side,
but,
um,
if somebody is a civilian,
wants to get a better understanding of the experiences that you've had,
aside from the books you recommended as the,
what,
what are other,
are there movies or documentaries that that do it?
Justice?
Restrepo Restrepo,
which I'm sure you've seen.
I have seen that's a heart wrenching.
It's unbelievable.
There's a,
there's an hour long,
I think it's history channel.
It's actually called a chance in hell.
The battle for Ramadi,
which is about [inaudible],
which is about the battle for Ramadi.
I like band of brothers.
I love the Pacific.
Did you see the Pacific?
I've had it recommended to me multiple times.
I mean,
it's,
it's the band of brothers in the Pacific,
so it's absolutely phenomenal.
And I had read several of the books that,
uh,
the Pacific is based on Eugene Sledge,
just,
you know,
uh,
I had read his book with the old breed.
Um,
I'd read a bunch of those books,
so I kind of knew and understood it.
And,
and that's just a phenomenal,
just a phenomenal
epic story and it,
and it does,
you know,
it,
it got to me like when I was watching it dies.
Got that feeling.
You know,
that feeling.
I remember there's one scene where,
where they're walking,
they're walking through the jungle in some island in the Pacific and nothing has
happened yet.
And I had that feeling because it's just like the feeling you'd have in Ramadi
and you'd be walking down the street.
If not,
if no shots had been fired yet.
It's this,
it's this feeling of,
of anticipation,
but it's fear.
It's an anticipation.
It's the unknown and it's the weighting sounds Erie.
It's waiting for it to happen and you know,
it's coming.
And I got that feeling watching,
you know,
watching the Pacific and that was in one of the early,
early ones.
And I said,
wow,
this is nailing it.
Well done.
Yeah,
I have to watch that.
That's been,
this is,
this is sort of the,
uh,
it definitely the,
the final push.
I need to watch that.
Um,
what,
um,
what would you put on a billboard if you had a,
if you could have one billboard anywhere,
what would you put on it?
Okay.
You know,
one on one of my,
one of my kind of,
I guess my mantra is a very simple one.
And that's discipline equals freedom.
I've found that,
you know,
as a,
as an individual,
the more disciplined you are and it's counterintuitive,
right?
The more disciplined you are,
the more freedom you actually have.
And you know,
you and I both know if you wake up early,
you,
you get more done and you end up with more free time.
So the more you manage your time,
the more disciplined you are with your time management,
the more free time you ended up having,
the more disciplined you are.
You know,
physically with your diet,
with physically,
the more freedom you have because you can do more stuff,
you have more freedom.
So the more disciplined you are,
the more freedom you have.
And what's interesting is how that transfers over to both military units and the
civilian sector that you know,
imposing or,
or when when an element or a unit or when a company is a disciplined group,
they actually end up with more freedom.
So,
you know,
I had a seal troop,
we were highly disciplined.
You know,
we had standard operating procedures for just about everything that we did.
And you'd think that that would restrain your creativity,
but it actually doesn't.
The more disciplined you are,
the easier I could say,
hey you four go take down that building.
And they knew what to do cause they were highly disciplined.
I knew what they were going to do because they were highly disciplined.
We understood what parameters they were going to stay within because we had
standard operating procedures to follow.
So that discipline,
both on an individual level and as a group equals freedom.
And just like anything else with leadership,
you can take that too far.
You know,
you can do,
you can discipline a,
an element or a person so much that they,
they break down and they no longer have creativity.
So just like the dichotomy of leadership,
you can go too strong with discipline and they end up breaking down or you can
give them too much freedom and they break down in the other direction.
Yeah.
This is this,
I'm really glad that you,
you mentioned that because I,
um,
I've realized in a way that my,
when I struggled the most kind of existentially or we're really just creatively,
it's one,
I have the fewest constraints.
I want positive constraints.
I need,
uh,
I need boxes.
Not that I could have to stay
within the box,
but that I can start at least coloring inside the box.
And,
uh,
that's part of the reason I've been so excited to adopt this rescue puppy,
Molly,
because it forces me to regiment and structure my day in such a way that I can
then plan around fixed objects.
And I think that whether it's in the military,
at least in my experience in business,
you want to reserve your creativity for the things that require creativity,
not for what should I,
what should the steps be when I'm doing a room clearance?
It's like,
no,
no.
You want a standard operating procedure so that your brain cycles are allocated
to the places where you need those brain cycles.
Right?
That's 100% right.
And,
uh,
so I've realized in the last few months for myself that what I thought I wanted,
right?
Which is freedom in the form of infinite options is not actually what I want at
all.
It's very stressful and you end up burning calories.
You burned 10 calories in a million directions,
you're fatigued and you didn't get shit done.
And,
uh,
so I'm actually in a way trying to figure out how I can say no to a thousand
things so that I can be fully creative on one or two things.
And,
um,
it's just,
it's,
it's one of the reasons I enjoy doing this podcast so much is,
and when you talk to people who have operated at the highest levels in any
field,
this kind of stuff comes up.
And after a while it's like,
Ferris idiot.
Do you get the message yet?
You've heard meditation from 80% of the people who've been on your podcast.
Maybe you should chill the fuck out and like sit down for 20 minutes every
morning.
Uh,
but the,
the one I'm talking about ownership and,
uh,
could you explain your book and why you decided to write it?
So,
first of all,
while I was still in the seal teams,
you know,
I had guys,
cause they,
once everyone knew I was getting out,
that guy said,
hey,
you know,
you need to write this stuff down.
You need to pass on these lessons learned.
And,
you know,
I did that in a,
uh,
in almost a doctrinal way and I captured those lessons learned and pass those
on.
And then when I started working with civilian companies,
you know,
Lafe and I,
my,
my business partner,
we'd started hearing the same thing,
which is,
hey,
do you guys have a reference?
Can we,
you know what,
we want to hand out some stuff to the rest of our people that couldn't make
this.
And Hey,
you guys really changed the way this group is operating.
We want to spread that to the rest of our groups.
Do you have a book we can give them?
Do you have reference material?
And you know,
eventually we said,
okay,
we,
we need to write something.
And so,
you know,
from,
from my perspective,
this is uh,
an opportunity for us to pass on the lessons that we learned and relearned that
had been,
you know,
some of them,
some of the,
some of the lessons we learned and talk about had been around for thousands of
years and some of them were,
were discovered a little bit more recently,
but they are definitely solid.
And they've been very well tested in a variety of environments,
starting with the harshest environment of the mall,
which is sustained,
violent urban combat.
And then they've,
we've brought them to dozens and dozens of companies and we keep hearing the
same thing.
Which is these work,
what,
what's the explanation behind the title?
Actually came from an email that I sent to a,
uh,
you know,
grew up a manager in a company and,
and the email basically said we,
when I was in the seal teams and I was a troop commander,
so I was in charge of task unit bruiser and we were getting ready to go on
deployment.
And occasionally the commodore,
which is a couple ranks above my boss,
actually one rank above my boss is a guy named the commodore,
which is,
you know,
a full bird colonel if you're in the Marine Corp,
the army.
And he's kind of in charge of all the seal teams on the west coast.
And so he would have occasional meetings where he'd bring in us the troop
commanders,
and we're like the front line guys.
And this is west coast of the u s west coast of the u s and the story that I
told him this email,
what was that?
He would go around the room because he wants to get some direct feedback from
the troops and he'd ask somebody,
you know,
okay,
well what do you need?
And these guys are my peers.
And you know,
someone would say,
well,
you know,
the boots that we have are okay in the hot weather,
but we're getting ready to be in a cooler environment.
We need new boots.
Uh,
and we need them by this date because that's our next training block.
Okay.
Got It.
And he gets the next person.
So you know,
when we're out at the desert training facility,
there's no Wifi Internet.
So our guys are disconnected and you know,
we really need to get wifi out there.
Okay.
Got It.
And the next guy would say,
we need more helicopter training support because we don't feel like we're
working around helicopters and off.
We really need that.
And eventually it'll get to me,
I need,
you know,
common would say,
Jocko,
what do you need?
And I would say we're going to start,
and I was stating the obvious,
which is if I have problems,
I'm going to handle them and I'm going to take care of them.
I'm not going to complain.
I took extreme ownership of my world and the way that work two fold was when I
did need something,
it number one,
it was something significant.
It was something real.
And when I told the commodore,
Hey boss,
we need this right here.
I would almost get it instantaneously because he knew that I really truly needed
it.
And so I'd written this,
kind of told that story and,
and talked about extreme ownership and to and owning everything in your world.
Because the other piece of that is you,
you complain,
you know,
people complain,
they place blame on other people.
And finally,
you know,
if your boss,
if Tim's boss isn't giving you the support you need,
who's fault is,
whose fault is it?
If your boss is not giving you what you need,
who's fault is that?
I suppose is my fault.
Plenty people,
plenty of people will say,
well,
it's my boss's fault.
No,
it's actually your fault because you haven't educated them.
You have an influence them,
you haven't,
you haven't explained to them in a manner that they understand why you need this
support that you need.
And so that's extreme ownership.
That's where the title came from.
Or you've made them like,
like you,
uh,
I suppose alluded to,
um,
you've made them immune to your requests because you're the boy who cries wolf.
Exactly.
And if you're constantly needy,
they will determine that nothing is important or,
or it's not a real urgent important request.
Yep.
Uh,
and that,
that really,
I mean,
that's extreme ownership in a nutshell is you're taking responsibility for
everything in your world.
And there's no one else to blame.
And when we do talk about bosses,
you know,
I,
I tell this to people all the time,
cause you know,
I always hear complaining about people's bosses and I tell people that
I worked for every different type of boss you could imagine,
you know,
superb tactical geniuses that were incredible leaders of men.
And I've worked for people that didn't know anything and were horrible.
And I had the same relationship with all of them,
which is I built up trust with them so that they trusted that I was going to do
the right thing and they gave me the support I needed.
And Th that's a,
that's a real,
I took ownership of those relationships to make sure that that was always the
case.
And that's another piece that I,
you know,
if you have a problem with your boss,
it's not your boss's fault,
it's your fault.
And obviously it's the same thing down the chain of command as well.
What,
what are some of the principles or lessons that the companies you've worked with
have found most valuable?
We'll cover and move is a big one covering the cover and move.
So if you and I were going to attack a building across the street where there
was enemy,
uh,
I would get in a window here and I would start shooting at them covering fire,
covering fire,
and you would move,
when you heard me shooting,
you would start to move and you'd find a better tactical position.
And then once you've gotten a better tackle position,
you would start shooting.
And I would move and eventually we would get to a position where we could kill
the enemy and take down the building.
So that's called cover and move.
And honestly,
when I started talking to companies,
I said to myself,
well,
how do I translate an actual gun fighting tactic?
I that's,
that's all it is.
A gun fighting tech.
How do you translate that to,
to accompany to a business?
And as soon as I started talking to,
you know,
businesses,
uh,
I mean the first business I talked to,
I realized that guess what,
every single business has multiple different elements within it.
Whether it's,
you know,
you've got an operational group,
you've got a manufacturing group,
you've got a sales group,
and guess what?
All of those elements have absolutely to work
together,
cover and move for each other.
Because if I'm the sales guy and I sell something and you're the manufacturer
and you don't manufacture it in time,
or it's faulty or whatever,
that we fail,
we fail.
Right?
And if you manufacture a bunch of perfect units and I can't sell any of them,
guess what we fail.
Right?
So that,
that's a huge one that people really grab onto because just about every company
experiences,
some need to cover and move.
And uh,
there there's so many maxims that are memorable from the military.
I mean,
one that I only got exposed to a few days ago.
And you mentioned it when we got started right here.
Um,
was,
you know,
the fact that I have,
I have two recorders.
And uh,
so what is,
what does the expression,
cause I,
I,
I was trained very early on to think about single points of failure actually.
My first job,
which was mass data storage.
So you always want redundancy.
They're all about redundancy,
whether that's,
you know,
a raid array,
uh,
or,
or anything else,
you don't want a single point of failure.
So what,
what was the expression that you used in two is one and one is non.
So it just means have a backup means how backup,
if you only have one of something,
it's going to disappear.
And the,
the structure of the book,
uh,
I really like,
and um,
you know,
I spoke with,
with Pete about this is could you describe it because seems like every chapter
has a story from combat,
the reflects a principal,
then you explain the principle and then you use a business story to show how
that translates exactly.
Right.
And uh,
what is your,
what do you think is a part of the book that people might not pay enough
attention to that they should pay more attention to?
Because I know there are aspects,
I'll just for instance,
like in the,
in the,
uh,
four hour chef,
I'll give an example.
People Focus,
when I'm talking about an accelerated learning framework,
they're like,
okay,
deconstruction,
got it.
Selection,
you know,
doing the 80,
20 analysis.
Got It.
Uh,
and then eat a sequence in.
Cool.
Got It.
And then stakes sending up consequences,
they kind of gloss over it.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
If you don't have sufficient incentive,
like a punishment or reward,
all that other stuff,
the how to stuff,
it doesn't matter.
Right.
But,
but they gloss over it.
And I think I take responsibility for that.
Like maybe I didn't highlight the importance enough,
but what are,
what are areas of the book or chapters that,
anything that comes to mind where you're like,
you know what,
people might gloss over this or pay less attention to it then they should.
Well I think,
I don't know if this will answer your question,
but what's been interesting on the feedback we've gotten is we,
we have different people find different chapters,
they latch onto different chapters.
And so there's even chapters where we were,
we,
you know,
we said,
hey,
you know,
maybe we should take the chapter out,
I don't know about this chapter or that chapter.
And we even got some feedback so that I would take the chaparral and literally
would get someone saying,
Hey,
the best chapter is the chapter that someone else told us to take out.
So I think that people are going to identify very easily what relates to them.
And you know,
there'll be a high point of this completely relates to me and there'll be some
other ones.
Oh yeah,
I've seen that before.
Not as much because of,
you know,
maybe that's a skill area that they have.
So they don't,
they don't really need to work on that.
But that's what I've,
I've found most interesting is that the variety of answers when people,
people like the different sections and they get something out of the,
out of the various chapters.
That's a,
that's a really,
that's a really good sign by the way.
And I know we were chatting,
um,
about this book and I'm excited to see what it does in the wild.
The,
uh,
what I've noticed for the books that I've written,
which are way,
way too long for any sane person to write them reading is a different story
because going to be like a choose your own adventure book.
But what I've done proofreading,
and I've had friends read,
the rule that I've decided on is to remove something.
You need a consensus to keep something.
You only need one person to love it.
So if I have one person who says,
I love this part,
it doesn't matter if nine out of 10 people say,
I hate it,
it stays in,
that's a good rule.
And,
uh,
because you don't need a book,
everything in a book to apply to every person.
It's just like if you had a commanding officer,
not everything that person would say we equally apply to you if there's,
if they're dealing with groups as you have dealt with groups and teams.
Uh,
so that's very promising sign.
Um,
there's so many questions I could ask you.
I don't even know where to start.
Let me,
uh,
let me take a quick glance at a few things here.
Um,
because I know we want to grab some food in not too,
not too short order.
Uh,
Jocko hungry.
Jack Andre,
Jocko smash.
I don't want Jagoda to smash me because I would be helpless.
Uh,
what do you talk to about seals
more versus civilians
as opposed to,
I mean,
obviously you have the,
the,
the comradery and common background of,
uh,
the,
the warfare experience,
right?
But aside from trading those stories,
uh,
what do you tend to talk to seals about more versus civilians?
Straight to the point when you're torn up?
When I go and talk to seals,
I spend time a little more time talking about,
well number one I talk about the tactics,
like the,
the actual on the ground tactics of what was happening and that's,
that's valuable lessons learned.
Another thing that I talk about in depth is around
the piece of risk mitigation.
Now as you know,
in the business world,
risk mitigation is huge and it's a matter of fact,
the first time I ever spent the day with a CEO and he said,
well what do you think of this stuff?
And I said,
well,
it's kind of like what I
used to do risk mitigation.
But when you're talking about your guys getting killed,
it's a whole nother ballgame.
And I remember a conversation I had with my commanding officer.
And so this is the type of thing that I would tell seals.
We're not on deployment yet.
So we're still back in America.
And my commanding officer brings me in and he says,
Hey Jocko,
you know,
he knew we were going to Ramadi.
He knew Ramadi was really bad.
And he said,
before you go on any operation,
I want you to think about if it is a worth,
if it is worth the risk of losing one of your guys.
And I said to him,
sir,
I,
I don't need to think about that.
I can tell you right now,
there's no operation you can give me.
You can task me with that is I would trade one of my guys for not going to
happen.
That being said,
we are going to on deployment to Iraq,
we have a mission and we have a job and we have a duty to execute that mission
and we will take risks and we'll do everything we can to mitigate those risks.
But if we're going to take zero risks than we might as well just stay here in
San Diego,
California.
So that's the kind of thing I think that,
you know,
cause people can be very risk averse,
even in the military solitary,
uh,
it can get very,
very risk averse and it's,
and it's understandable,
you know,
it's understandable that you say,
look,
what is,
what's,
is this worth the risk or not?
And my point always was,
you have to just mitigate the risks as much as you can,
but there are going to be risks you you're going to have to deal with.
Absolutely.
Well,
it end in military context.
I mean,
it seems like a huge risk is not making a decision,
which is a decision in and of itself.
Uh,
and when I look at,
say,
you know,
the Laird Hamilton's the world is an incredible big wave surfer or some of
these,
uh,
just interviewed Jimmy Chin Who's one of the key climbers.
I mean,
he's effectively a professional athlete in this documentary called Meru,
which is about this,
uh,
the shark's Fin,
and I want to say it's India,
but it might be Pakistan.
This,
this rock face that has defeated the world's best climbers for 30 years.
Um,
they are all people view all of these people is massive risk takers.
And when you actually sit down and talk to these guys,
you realize they are expert risk mitigators and uh,
and I think it's very easy to miss come to the mistaken conclusion and business
for example,
that you only win big if you bet the farm.
And in fact when I talked to some of these companies here in Silicon Valley for
instance,
that have uh,
become worth billions and billions of dollars,
uh,
some rightly some maybe in the irrational exuberance of our current day,
but many I think rightly so.
Uh,
you see that in my experience,
in no cases have,
they bet the farm,
they have evaluated the downside.
They've,
they've tried to measure the maximum allowable downside.
They know not only kind of their bet and their bet size,
but when they're going to fold a,
they have an exit strategy for,
for minimizing or capping losses.
And unfortunately,
I think that the,
the kind of renegade risk taker gets romanticized in a lot of different spheres,
including business.
And they get the magazine covers in some cases because it makes for a good
story,
but there's a huge survivorship bias,
right?
Because you don't get to see,
you know,
the,
the nine out of 10 who tried the same excessively ballsy move and got their
balls chopped off.
You don't,
they don't make it to the magazine cover.
I often talk about the fact I'll get up and brief a bunch of missions that we
did,
you know,
and,
and when,
when I get done,
I'll be saying,
you know,
I didn't brief you guys on any missions that we didn't do.
You know,
there was missions,
plenty missions that we looked at.
We weighed the risk versus the reward.
And we said,
you know what,
not worth the risk.
And so we did the exact same thing.
I think you're 100% right.
So it's a very high level.
Risk mitigation is,
is the same in business and in combat.
Yeah.
And it's,
um,
you know,
I remember hearing an expression,
I don't know who to attribute this to,
but it's like if you cap your downside,
the upside takes care of itself.
Um,
and I'm not sure if that applies in every circumstance,
but it's a,
might not be a perfect guideline,
but it's a helpful guideline where it's like,
if you take enough shots and you've constantly kept your downside,
if you have a couple of outliers,
they give you disproportionate upside in the long run.
I mean,
you're going to average out ahead and beat most people,
especially the people who were cavalier.
Um,
who's the,
who's a historical figure that you identify with,
if any.
You know,
I talked about David Hackworth,
then I definitely,
uh,
definitely identify or I,
I would,
you know,
I look up to him,
um,
it in,
by the way,
I didn't,
you know,
he became,
uh,
piece guy.
I mean,
that's,
that's where he ended up was living on Australia as a,
you know,
premier leading the pack on,
anti nuclear weapons.
So it's,
it's,
you know,
it's not,
not your average guy.
A historical figure.
It's a tough question.
I'm not sure what my answer would be.
Yeah.
I'll stick with Hackworth.
Alright.
Hackworth.
It is,
what is something most people would be surprised to know about you?
Okay.
Again,
I think it's the,
uh,
the same thing I talked about earlier with the fact that
they expect,
you know,
I have a certain look to me you might say,
then I look like,
you know,
kind of a serial killer bind with,
some kind of Psychopathic,
uh,
steroid mutant and,
and,
you know,
so people I think have a loose on my texting,
my girlfriend.
I was just trying to prepare.
I think,
uh,
there's some kind of surprise,
I think when people hear me string a sentence together and say,
oh,
okay,
that's what I think that's surprising to a lot of people.
It makes me think of this comedian Jim Gaffigan,
really funny guy who's like,
ah,
these talking about how attractive people have it.
Really easy because he's like,
and then there's a beautiful woman and she has a book and people are like,
Ooh,
she's beautiful.
And she can read double threat.
But uh,
no.
You're very good at string sentences together.
Uh,
do you have any bad habits or bad habits that you're working to overcome?
Bad Habits?
I can rephrase.
Non Ideal habits or what are you trying to improve about your song?
I'm trying to improve everything all the time.
I mean,
that's a much easier question cause because I want to be faster,
stronger,
more limber,
uh,
smarter,
quicker.
Whittier always everything,
always trying to improve.
So if the,
if you were to prioritize those currently,
let's just say over the next 12 months,
which are the areas that you're hoping to most,
uh,
push into overdrive for improve upon?
You know,
I think
I literally wake up every day and I'm trying to do all those things.
I don't know how I prioritize them,
which w and,
and the reason I think is because they're not mutually exclusive.
Right?
You know,
one of my,
one of my law is a combat is prioritize and execute,
which means if you've got multiple problems going on,
if you try and handle them all at once,
you will absolutely fail.
So prioritize and execute.
You look at what problems you have,
you pick the most impactful one or the biggest threat and you solve that one and
then you move onto the next one,
the next one,
so forth.
But you know,
I can definitely read and work out and stretch all in the same day.
These are not mutually exclusive things.
And,
and I'll,
I'll do them all.
You will.
You were right.
And I guess it is in a way kind of,
it could be viewed as a trick question.
I was reading,
um,
a number of transcribed lectures by Krishna Murti.
And he talked about,
and I'm probably butchering this by paraphrasing it,
but the fact that people talking about stuff,
you know,
changing one small thing at a time.
And I do think there's a place for that and behavioral change and certainly a
plus.
Things like dog training
or human training.
Uh,
you know,
operant conditioning,
classical conditioning and blah,
blah,
shaping and all that.
But there are cases where the every,
the elements are so intertwined.
You can't change one without changing all the others.
Uh,
and uh,
so you do have to kind of try to,
if he can't eat the elephant in one small bite at a time,
you have to try to eat the whole fucking elephant.
Uh,
all right.
Let me ask a couple of cheesy questions just cause I just,
cause I'm,
I'm feeling the spirit moved me here.
Um,
you walk into a bar,
what do you order from the bartender?
Water.
Do you not drink?
I'll go.
Nope.
You did not.
No caffeine or very limited caffeine.
No alcohol.
What other,
what other things?
Are there any other things you abstained from that would surprise people
perhaps?
I don't think so.
Okay.
Uh,
what do you listen to?
What type of music do you listen to and working out?
So I,
I grew up listening to heavy metal and hardcore music.
Primarily black Sabbath was kind of my indoctrination into [inaudible] world.
Good choice.
I remember one of my buddies grown up,
you know,
he's was praising black sabbath and he said,
music throughout the,
throughout the history of the world has been meant to,
you know,
make people feel better and bring them joy.
And Black Sabbath has absolutely nothing to do with that.
I think that's,
you know,
that darkness again,
we going back to that theme of darkness and I think that Black Sabbath was the
first group that I heard that I said,
that's what I feel.
What is that?
And I,
and I latched onto it and you know,
from then I started saying,
what's harder?
What's darker than that?
And you know,
I ended up listening to a lot of hardcore,
I'll give a shout out to black flag hill.
Yeah.
Lifelike black flag.
My War side too.
Which if you,
if you listen to black black flag,
you'll even,
even to me when I was growing up,
I thought,
yeah,
these guys are okay,
whatever,
no big deal.
Punk rock.
But you get to my war side too.
And there was a paradigm shift and it was a completely new thing.
And that was another,
I had black flag,
my war side too on my record player for,
you know,
maybe even a year where that's just what I listened to.
So you know,
that.
Um,
and then,
you know,
again,
a lot of the hardcore stuff that I grew up listening to,
I still listen to that today.
It's still,
you know,
on my,
on my iPhone and what I plugged into a,
if I was to say some of the more modern music that I listened to,
I'd,
I'd throw out the white buffalo,
the White Buffalo.
Yeah.
Who's a
great,
just an incredible,
incredible position.
And what's incredible about him is he's,
he writes songs and sing songs that have impact and leave a mark and he's,
he plays acoustic guitar and a,
it's not heavy metal by any stretch of the imagination,
but it is hard and it is raw.
And it is true.
And one of the few concerts I've seen in the last 10 years has been
buffalo,
white,
white buffalo and white buffalo.
So I've seen him a bunch of times.
Every time it comes around and go and see him,
I'll have to check that out.
White Buffalo,
I won't even get into it,
but very interesting mythological,
uh,
or it should have traditional native American associations with the White
Buffalo.
Also,
people can Google that and check it out.
But that's,
you can,
you can go deep looking into the stories associated with the white buffalo also.
Uh,
just a few more questions.
If you could give yourself your 25 year old self advice,
what would it be?
Yeah,
so I'm 25 years old.
I'm at seal team one and I need to know that you don't know everything.
And,
and,
and right now I know that right now that I don't know everything and I still
have a ton to learn and it's like kind of like,
again,
we'll go back to Jujitsu,
but I told that story earlier when I first learned a couple of basic moves.
I thought I knew Jujitsu.
I thought it was good.
I got it.
Yeah.
And then you know,
now and you know,
I've been training for 20 something years and I know that there's still tons of
my,
I know,
I don't know,
a quarter of what I need to know,
a 10th of what I need to know.
And it's the same thing with everything in life.
You know,
you're going to,
you've got to have an open mind.
You've got to be ready to learn all the time and always,
always be
seeking out that knowledge because it doesn't just smack you.
You know,
you've got to seek it out and talk to people and,
and that's how you're learning gets smarter.
What,
uh,
how,
how old are you now if you don't mind me asking?
I'm 44.
44.
What about your 35 year old self?
So now I'm,
I'm in Ramadi and
looking back now.
Okay.
I would say
relish that moment,
which I did,
but I would say relish that moment.
Jocko,
this has been fascinating and a real honor.
I appreciate you taking the time.
Where can people find more about you?
About the book,
about Your Company and work in the,
uh,
were the best places to visit you and everybody listening,
of course,
the,
the links and so on to everything we talked about in this discussion.
We'll be@afourhourworkweekallspelledoutforourworkweek.com and just click on
podcast.
But,
uh,
where can people find more about you and your work online?
So we have a Facebook for the book that's coming out.
Extreme ownership is,
this is where you can find that on Facebook.
We have a Twitter for extreme ownership as well.
And Lafe and I are both,
uh,
extremely,
inept at social media.
So it's a,
we're,
we're trying to make some improvements there and as we,
as we get people interested,
we'll do more.
And you know,
I have,
I actually have a Twitter account.
I think I've posted one Twitter statement.
Yeah,
it's kind of weird.
You know,
I,
I always feel like I never liked people that just like talked for no reason.
Right.
And I kind of get the feeling when you're posting something on Twitter,
you're kind of talking for no reason.
Yeah.
And so I don't know,
maybe as people start to ask me questions on Twitter and now I have a
conversation cause to just sit there and talk,
it feels awkward to me and not really described the Brita.
You just had perfect strangers on the Internet.
I will,
I'll tell you what I'll do after we get off.
I'll show you how I use Twitter for extremely fast information gathering and
polling and I think you'll find that interesting.
I'm sure there are some very practical applications.
So guys,
I will link to all of this website is,
I always mispronounce this,
is it at Chalan or Exelon?
It's actually as Chalan Chalan e c h e l o n front.com.
And I'll link to all this stuff but I'll say it anyway,
uh,
follow Jocko so that he is forced to interact on Twitter,
which is the sort of the antithesis of
the act.
More talk,
less ethos that I so respect.
But I will show him some interesting ways to implement it.
At Jocko Willink on Twitter at j.
O c k o W.
I l l,
I N K and a extreme ownership will also be on Twitter and Facebook.
I'll link to all this stuff but that will be in the show notes and Jocko,
thanks so much.
I really appreciate the time.
Appreciate the opportunity to thank you.
All right man.
We'll get some food and a to be continued.
So guys,
let us know what you thought.
Uh,
check out the book.
You should really check out the book extreme ownership.
I've been reading it and very highly actionable,
very easy to digest.
You have lessons wrapped into stories so you have some,
some,
some sugarcoating that will help compel this and propel this into your brand so
you can actually use this information and as always,
thank you for listening.
Until next time,
learn,
experiment,
test and educate yourself.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
Your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups
that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it and here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't great investing
is a marathon,
not a sprint and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on the show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of SCC regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim,
it's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Now,
I do have to read a mandatory disclaimer.
Wealthfront Inc is an SEC registered investment advisor.
Investing in securities involves risks and there's the possibility of losing
money.
Past performance is no guarantee of future results.
Please visit wealthfront.com to read their full disclosure.
So check it out,
guys.
This is one of the hottest,
most innovative companies coming out of Silicon Valley,
and they're killing it.
They've become massively popular.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you,
and you can use that information however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.